merci pour cette troisième commission de
la journée bien chargé
nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir
aujourd'hui Monsieur Christophe Béchu
madame Loisier voilà merci
ministre chargé de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion on est
territoire tout un programme alors que
le Sénat vient d'adopter assez largement
le projet de loi d'accélération de la
production d'énergie renouvelable votre
audition monsieur le ministre arrive à
point nommé pour nous permettre
d'apprécier les forts budgétaires et
fiscales consentis par le gouvernement
en faveur de notre transition
énergétique et plus largement écologique
alors je ne sais s'il c'est le plaisir
de venir devant notre commission ou une
certaine forme d'anxiété mais si on
mesure votre motivation en nombre de SMS
que moi-même et mes collègues ont reçu
avant la avant
l'audition
réduire nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre de 55% d'ici 2030 atteindre la
neutralité carbone à l'horizon 2005 pose
50 suppose une action sans précédent
dans plusieurs secteurs économiques
essentiels qui nous intéresse bien sûr
l'énergie le logement la mobilité
monsieur cadet c'est aussi d'une
conception plus durable tout en étant
réaliste de la ville et de la ruralité
plus largement de l'urbanisation dont
nous avons besoin notre commission ayant
déjà entendu la ministre de la
transition énergétique à deux reprises
en juillet et en octobre dernier sur la
flambée des prix les énergies
renouvelables et la sécurité
d'approvisionnement je vous propose que
nous actions votre audition sur les
crédits liés à la rénovation énergétique
à la précarité énergétique aux mutations
sociales et territoriales qui vous
reviennent avant de céder la parole à
nous rapporteurs thématiques je voudrais
vous poser plusieurs questions
ma première série de questions concerne
le budget que vous présentez en 2020 et
2021 le gouvernement alloué à l'énergie
14 milliards sur les 110 milliards du
plan de relance et 12 milliards sur les
30 milliards du plan France 2003 ce sont
des sommes tout à fait considérables qui
ont vocation à soutenir la rénovation
énergétique ou la mobilité propre or
cette année les autorisations
d'engagement sont inférieures de 25%
montant globaux annoncé y a-t-il une
difficulté d'exécution autre sujet
majeur le gouvernement propose de créer
un fonds d'accélération de la transition
écologique dans les territoires dotés de
1 milliard 5 or dans le même temps il
n'a prévu aucune autorisation
d'engagement pour deux fonds existants
institués à l'initiative de notre
commission suite à la loi énergique
climat de 2019 le premier vise les
fermetures de centrales et le second
l'accompagnement social de leur salarié
qu'entendez-vous faire sur ces sujets
s'agissant de énergétique le projet de
loi finance adoptée par l'Assemblée
nationale prévoit un ciblage du taux
réduit de TVA à 5,5 applicable en
supprimant les éligibilité des travaux
dit indissociablesment liés or ce taux
réduit constitue très clairement le
premier des leviers publics de la
rénovation énergétique puisqu'il atteint
4,5 milliards soit 3 fois plus que les
crédits alloués à ma prime à ma prime
rénove dont vous nous parlerez sûrement
n'est-il pas inopportun de le remettre
ainsi en cause pour ce qui concerne la
conversion automobile le commissaire
chargé du marché intérieur Thierry
Breton a reconnu lui-même les
difficultés économiques mais aussi
sociales du tout électrique d'ici 2035
or la prime à la conversion dispositif
de reprise des véhicules anciens et
moins usité que le bonus automobile
dispositif de soutien véhicules neuf sur
cet objectif du tout électrique est-ce
que le gouvernement dispose d'une étude
sur les conséquences économiques et
environnementales
du remplacement de tous les véhicules
actuels par des véhicules électriques
est-ce que l'on est sûr que l'empreinte
environnementale que ces véhicules en
termes de fabrication et de
fonctionnement est moins élevée que
celle des véhicules thermiques je ne dis
pas ça pour contester ce choix mais bien
sûr pour l'éclairer ma deuxième série de
questions portent sur la politique que
vous conduisez pour ce qui concerne les
objectifs du Zéro artificialisation
nette vous n'êtes bien sûr pas sans
ignorer l'importance de ce sujet dans
les territoires et au Sénat je ne vous
poserai qu'une brève question à ce sujet
puisque vous saurez bien sûr bientôt
entendu dans le cadre de la mission
conjointe que nous menons au Sénat lors
de votre prise de fonction au sein du
gouvernement vous aviez laissé la porte
ouverte
en tout cas au moins entre bâiller pour
appeler les adaptations au cadre
juridique du zan que nous savons
désormais mal taillés par endroits nous
avons pu échanger plusieurs fois à ce
sujet et nous constatons que nous sommes
en novembre 2022 que la conférence des
scottes ont déjà du rendre leur travaux
que la révision des stradettes sa mort
et que pourtant nul évolution notable
d'usane n'est encore amorcée donc vous
nous direz quels sont vos intentions
d'autre part vous savez que le
financement du zan sera le nerf de la
guerre sans moyens pour la
réhabilitation du bâti le recyclage des
friches la renaturation et sans
adaptation
de la fiscalité nous ne pourrons pas
bousculer vers un modèle d'usane qui
soit économiquement viable en dehors
d'une mesure relativement anecdotique
j'ose le dire concernant l'exonération
de la taxe d'aménagement sur les sites
dépollués renaturés nous n'avons rien vu
d'autre et l'annonce du fond vert au
contour pour l'instant assez flou nous
laisse pour l'instant dans le
questionnement
je vous propose maintenant de répondre à
cette première question pardon d'avoir
été trop curieuse probablement et trop
bavarde et je passerai ensuite la parole
au rapporteur commencez par Daniel
grimmiele puis à Valérie sur sur le zan
voilà monsieur le ministre à vous et je
précise pour mes collègues pardon
monsieur le ministre que malheureusement
monsieur le ministre ne peut rester
jusqu'à 18h 18h15 et que nous sommes
déjà beaucoup à poser des questions
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs je ne vais pas
faire de propos introductifs ce qui me
permettra de pouvoir étancher le plus
possible
la soif des questions que vous auriez et
d'y répondre compte tenu de surcroît à
la fois de la latitude du chant et des
auditions que vous avez déjà pu conduire
le périmètre dont j'ai la responsabilité
qui comprend trois ministères délégués
et deux secrétariat d'État qui va du
logement au transport en passant par
l'écologie qui rejoint aussi bien les
questions de la chasse de la
biodiversité avec un agenda
international que vous connaissez qui
emprunte le chemin de la décarbonation
de notre pays avec les trajectoires qui
sont liées à la planification écologique
et la partie cohésion des territoires
fait que si j'entreprenais de vous
décrire par le menu les différents
sujets ou les différentes options je
risquerais où de réitérer les auditions
que vous avez pu conduire je pensais
Olivier Klein la semaine dernière sur la
partie spécifique logement qui
représente environ 20 milliards sur les
41 milliards le périmètre budgétaire
pour l'année 2023 qui arrive et dont
j'ai la responsabilité ou d'évoquer des
sujets qui ne présentent pas à vos yeux
un caractère d'urgence ou d'intérêt
particulier juste un mot pour vous dire
que pour la première fois de plus
intense
les effectifs du pôle de l'écologie au
sens large ne baisseront pas
le ministère dont je m'occupe et celui
qui a perdu le plus d'effectifs en
pourcentage depuis 20 ans quel que soit
la couleur des gouvernements une moyenne
de 1000 agents par an quand on
additionne les agents qui travaillent au
sein du ministère ou dans les dizaines
d'agences qui sont rattachés de l'office
français à la biodiversité en passant
par l'ADEME Météo France l'IGN le cerema
et quelques autres
cet effort il est pas seulement pour
l'année 2023 il est pour la totalité du
quinquennat et il masque un renforcement
des effectifs liés au fait que dans le
périmètre des effectifs du ministère il
y a la Société du Grand Paris qui rendra
plusieurs centaines de postes à un
horizon 2 ans quand elle aura achevé une
partie de son programme et de ses
travaux ce qui nous permettra de
conforter des opérateurs voilà le propos
que je souhaitais avoir
et les crédits budgétaires augmentent de
8% madame la Présidente vous m'avez posé
des questions qui pour certaines sont
directement dans mon périmètre
ministériel pour d'autres le sont en
pointillés et qui pour certaines ne le
sont pas
en particulier vous m'avez interrogé sur
les centrales nucléaires et leurs
salariés et ça c'est totalement chez
Agnès panier renacher au titre de la
transition énergétique et donc je
préfère ne pas m’aventurer sur une
réponse qui serait
orthogonale par rapport au sujet que
j'ai l'habitude de suivre vous m'avez à
l'inverse interrogé de manière directe
sur le sujet du fond d'accélération de
la transition écologique sur lequel je
peux pas seulement vous répondre puisque
je me réjouis que la première ministre
est retenue cette proposition que je lui
ai faite l'idée elle est très basique
elle est de dire qu'on n'arrivera pas à
faire la transition écologique sans les
élus et qu'on a aujourd'hui un problème
qu'on ne fait pas suffisamment confiance
au territoire or c'est là où se prennent
les décisions qui permettent en vrai de
faire la transition écologique très
concrètement ce fond qui n'est plus d'un
milliard et demi mais qui est de 2
milliards d'euros nous y avons ajouté un
demi milliard d'euros dans la copie qui
vous sera présenté dans quelques jours
permet de financer de manière
déconcentrée tous les projets qui sont
favorables pour l'environnement je
m'explique on a aujourd'hui listé une
quinzaine d'items qui pourraient faire
l'objet de
l'idée c'est de les transmettre au
préfet de département qui disposeront
d'enveloppes pour éviter d'aller
allonger des procédures il n'y aura ni
appel à manifestation d'intérêt ni appel
à projet des sommes qui seront
immédiatement disponibles et qui
permettront d'aller couvrir des besoins
qui correspondent aux items quels sont
ces items la liste pourrait être
complétée mais l'idée que c'est ou bon
pour l'atténuation ou bon pour la
biodiversité ou bon pour l'atténuation
du réchauffement climatique et la
boussole qui guidera les choix ça va de
l'érosion du trait de côte pour les
communes littorales qui du coup pourront
bénéficier de crédit jusqu'à des mesures
par exemple sur la rénovation
des lampadaires pour faire en sorte de
changer des ampoules thermiques en
ampoule LED pour diminuer son empreinte
carbone en passant par des mesures de
montagne qui permettent de se préserver
y compris des mesures de protection
contre les feux de forêt en considérant
que c'est de l'adaptation réchauffement
climatique pourraient faire l'objet
d'une partie de ce dispositif les deux
milliards d'euros ça n'est pas pour
toute la vie c'est pour la seule année
de 2023 le niveau du des crédits de
paiement tient compte du fait que comme
il nous faudra malgré tout la
certification des services faits on
n'est pas totalement certain qu'on
pourra verser la totalité de les sommes
sur l'année qui arrivent mais c'est
engagement de 2 milliards il ne vaut que
pour 2023 et j'ai voulu un dispositif
souple pour que les élus sont
saisissants ont montré l'intérêt et la
nécessité de reconduire un dispositif
qui a le mérite d'être extrêmement
concret les sommes elles seront
ventilées à l'échelle des préfectures en
fonction des poids de population
accompagné par une sorte de FAQ ou de
petits guides sur la manière de s'en
servir avec ensuite une ventilation par
les préfets de départements qui nous
assurent que toutes les collectivités en
bénéficiant et je vous invite à poser
des questions dans le cadre de l'examen
si vous le souhaitez mais on l'a conçu
de la manière la plus simple qui soit et
on avance avec l'AMF pour les quelques
angles morts de manière à être certain
que le dispositif sera effectif au bout
du bout vous m'avez interrogé sur la
voiture électrique
le dossier est d'abord un dossier
industrie mais pour le coup il rejoint
directement et la transition énergétique
et la transition écologique
la voiture électrique
vous avez raison de souligner que il
peut y avoir là aussi des angles morts
en particulier si les voitures
électriques que nous produisons ont une
masse moyenne significativement plus
élevée que les voitures thermiques
puisque l'empreinte carbone d'un
véhicule
sa trace entre guillemets
environnementale ça n'est pas seulement
sa consommation pendant la durée de sa
vie c'est la consommation au moment de
sa production il faut donc toujours
réfléchir en termes de cycle de vie
quand on parle d'environnement on a donc
un premier sujet c'est d'éviter d'aller
jeter ou d'aller mettre à la case des
voitures qui seraient récentes puisqu'il
faut deux tonnes de pétrole pour
produire en moyenne un véhicule on a un
deuxième sujet par rapport au poids
moyen de ces véhicules parce que la
masse a un impact immédiat au moment de
la construction sur l'empreinte et
pendant la durée de la vie sur la taille
de la batterie et donc sur la part de
métro précieux qu'il faut pour être
capable de le construire mais aussi sur
un certain d'autres phénomènes de
pollution qui sont ça va être technique
vous pardonnerez mais au cœur de la
nouvelle norme recette a été évoqué par
le commissaire c'est-à-dire les pneus et
les freins et les conséquences en termes
d'abrasion qui peuvent délivrer un
certain nombre de particules fines et
qui peuvent avoir des conséquences en
revanche vous avez des études qui
permettent de démontrer en fonction du
poids à partir de combien de milliers de
kilomètres le thermique l'emporte
l'électrique l'emporte sur le thermique
en tant qu'empreinte globale et de ce
point de vue il y a à la fois pas de
doute sur l'empreinte environnementale
mais il y a deux surcroît un autre
phénomène c'est la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique au-delà de
l'empreinte carbone et donc la nécessité
qu'on fasse en sorte de limiter le
réchauffement de la planète avec toutes
les conséquences que ça et les coûts de
l'inaction qui sont monstrueux puisque
le climat est un usurier que plus on
retarde ou plus la température augmente
en termes de degré plus les coudes
d'adaptation seront élevés chaque
dixième de degré compte on a aujourd'hui
un débat sur sq1 5 on arrivera à les
tenir il faudrait pas qu'on se dise que
si on n'arrive pas à faire un 5 on a
qu'à ne rien faire parce que la vérité
c'est que un 7 c'est mieux que un 8 que
2 c'est mieux que de deux et donc on a
de toute façon l'intérêt à agir
je précise pour aller très très vite là
dessus que on a un certain nombre de
choses sur lesquelles il faut qu'on
travaille
1 si on développe les véhicules
électriques avec des importations
massives qui proviennent du bout du
monde du jean qui sont alimentés par du
charbon nous aurons un problème
environnemental et donc la nécessité de
faire en sorte que ce soit des véhicules
européens ou français est une nécessité
il faut pas être naïf les États-Unis
viennent au travers de leur IRL annoncé
un plan qui se veut officiellement très
vertueux d'un point de vue climatique
qui masque aussi une politique
protectionniste avec des soutiens à du
made in USA auquel il faut qu'on soit
capable sur le plan européen de répondre
et en particulier demain le leasing à
100 euros ou les primes qu'on est en
mesure d'apporter il faut qu'on les
cibles avec une vision qui consiste à
défendre notre industrie pour permettre
là aussi de conserver des emplois sur
notre territoire j'ajoute qu'on a un
sujet de pas de temps Madame la
Présidente la vérité c'est que
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas de véhicule
électrique d'occasion ou quasiment pas
et donc on a un souci puisqu'on a
imaginé des dispositifs de primes à la
conversion ou de bonus écologique mais
comme je n'ai pas d'offre
d'occasion je me retrouve à additionner
ces aides en face de prix de véhicules
neuves qui laissent à une charge et un
reste à payer qui est beaucoup trop
élevé pas seulement pour les classes
moyennes on parle de véhicule avec des
prix moyen à 30000 € et de dispositifs
d'aide quand vous les cumulez qui
atteignent 14 ou 15000 € le compte y est
donc pas pour des véhicules neufs d'où
la nécessité 1 d'avoir une filière de
l'occasion qui permette d'être
accompagnée parce que quand d'un point
de vue théorique vous additionnez les
niveaux de prime une voiture à 10.000
euros vous pouvez avoir un reste à payer
à 3000 le problème c'est qu'elle
n'existe pas aujourd'hui sur le marché
parce qu'on n'a pas la maturité et que
les producteurs européens aujourd'hui
font des SUV ou des voitures de grandes
gabarits donc avec des prix moyen
d'entrée sur le marché qui sont trop
élevés par rapport à ce que serait nos
besoins
deuxième sujet il faut qu'on mise sur le
rétrofit le rétrofit c'est je garde ma
voiture je change le moteur ça évite de
refaire la totalité de l'empreinte
carbone en allant lancer la construction
complète on a une filière qui est à
structurer qui pose quelques difficultés
mais qui peut permettre à court terme
d'accompagner une partie de la filière
il y a des investissements qui sont
conduits là-dessus enfin il y a un
dispositif de prêt à taux zéro au niveau
des zones affaiblissement qui est lancée
et qui méritera d'être étudié accompagné
sur lequel on aura peut-être quelques
occasions de revenir on est à 1 million
de véhicules électriques aujourd'hui
dans le pays sur un parc qui est
en schématisant de manière extrêmement
basique d'un peu moins de 40 millions
nous allons tour de 40 millions on a des
marges de progression mais c'est 13% des
immatriculations au cours de l'année
2013 on est déjà d'ores et déjà sur un
nombre d'immatriculation de voitures
électriques ou hybrides sur l'année 2022
qui est supérieur à la totalité de
l'année 2021 il y a donc aussi un pli
qui est en train d'être pris sur le zan
j'ai reçu hier soir tard et donc je n'ai
pas eu le temps de le regarder et
pourtant je savais qu'avec l'audition
d'aujourd'hui j'aurai la question le
rapport des agences d'urbanisme sur la
réécriture totale du décret nomenclature
quand nous nous sommes vus dès le mois
de juillet au monde de ma prise de
fonction vous m'avez dit trois ou quatre
choses un
il y a des décrets le 29 avril qui ont
été pris sont concertation avec les
parlementaires et qui pourra certains de
choses disent le contraire de ce que la
CMP avait arrêté j'ai donc intimé au
préfet l'ordre de lever les stylos dès
le début du mois d'août après qu'on se
soit vu pour dire surtout ne l'est pas
appliquer les décrets du 29 avril qui
font l'objet d'un certain nombre de
contestation au même moment pour ne pas
réitérer les mêmes erreurs qu'on fasse
pas en chambre un truc qui consiste à
dire que et artificiel ou est naturel
tel ou tel espace avec par exemple les
jardins municipaux qui sont considérés
comme des espaces artificialisés dans la
version précédente du décret
nomenclature on a convenu qu'on allait
demander à des villes et à des agences
d'urbanisme de travailler sur le décret
de nous en proposer un nouveau c'est ce
que j'ai reçu hier
vous m'avez interpellé sur le fait que
nous ne pouvions pas conserver un
dispositif pour les grands projets
nationaux je pense assez de Nord-Europe
je pense à des lignes LGV je pense à des
centrales nucléaires qui soient imputées
sur le compte des régions et qui amène
parfois une double peine que des
territoires qui n'ont pas été
désenclavés se retrouvent à avoir
aujourd'hui une artificialisation qui va
les priver d'une capacité de
développement alors que des territoires
qui ont bénéficié par le passé ont droit
grâce à ça à la moitié de
l'artificialisation provoquée par ses
grands projets qui va leur permettre de
disposer d'un crédit je vous annonce que
nous ferons un compter à part de tous
ces projets nationaux le seul sujet qui
reste et qui sera dans la discussion
avec vous c'est qu'est-ce qu'un grand
projet national une LGV et le sel
Nord-Europe il y a pas de doute est-ce
qu'on va plus loin il y a deux questions
dans la question est-ce qu'on fait un
compter à part des grands projets
régionaux
dans une optique de soutien économique
et puis une demandée par certains je
vous y annonce que pour le coup je n'y
suis pas favorable je pense à un
président de région du nord de la France
qui dit il faut non seulement faire un
tir à un compte à part national mais les
grands projets nationaux ne devraient
pas être comptés dans la trajectoire
d'artificialisation du pays je considère
qu'il faut évidemment intégrer ça dans
la trajectoire d'artificialisation pour
une raison simple on peut avoir des avis
différents mais personne ne peut
sérieusement prétendre que le fait qu'on
est artificialisé davantage en 50 ans
qu'en 500 ans et la preuve qu'on n'a pas
des marges de manœuvre
il n'y avait pas de lotissement au 17e
au 18e siècle nos anciens étaient
je vais vous répondre la progression de
la population en l'espace de 50 ans mes
chers collègues ça n'est pas le
doublement de la population du pays il y
a une décorrélation complète entre
l'artificialisation d'un côté et la
réalité de la progression de la
population de l'autre
parents et les enfants on peut pardon
je vous entends mais je vous invite à
bien mesurer que la question de
l'artificialisation n'est pas une
question mineure
c'est la question de la recharge de la
pratique c'est la question de la
capacité à disposer des lieux qui nous
permettent d'aller faire du captage de
carbone c'est la question de la
nécessité si on veut relocaliser une
partie de nos productions de notre
agriculture de notre possibilité de
pouvoir le faire et c'est la question
des solutions qui sont fondées sur la
nature j'ajoute un élément
il reste finalement deux points le
premier auquel je sais que le Senna est
sensible c'est la question des
territoires ruraux nous réfléchissons à
une sorte de garantie rurale je
l'appelle comme ça à ce stade qui
permettent de pouvoir conserver une
espérance dans toutes les communes en se
disant que ça n'est pas parce qu'on a
une petite commune qu'on a zéro droit à
construire pour autant l'idée qu'on
appliquerait pas le zan en dessous d'un
certain nombre de d'habitants ne serait
pas raisonnable si on veut être capable
d'avoir une trajectoire qui soit
vertueuse et puis le deuxième c'est
est-ce qu'il faut laisser au bénéfice
des régions dans le cadre du stradette
un dispositif avec les craintes de
certains territoires de considérer que
c'est la région qui décide il y aura des
arbitrages qui se feront de manière
différentielle
le système il a été pensé et le point
d'arriver sur lequel vous êtes mis
d'accord assemblés Sénat c'était celui
de dire que si on appliquait une règle
aveugle on divise par deux pour tout le
monde c'était plus injuste que tout
autiste système parce que celui qui
avait beaucoup artificialisé avait plus
de droits que celui qui avait été
vertueux et qu'ensuite on se retrouvait
dans une situation où on n'avait pas de
possibilités de coopération territoriale
et on a beau tourner le truc dans tous
les sens si je veux territorialiser et
s'y tenir compte un minimum de ce qui se
passe il faut quand même que j'ai une
échelle qui soit pas l'intercommunalité
et qui m'amène à utiliser suffisamment
importante pour être capable de répartir
ses droits pour autant on a aussi nous
l'entendons des régions qui nous disent
que elle elles ne veulent pas porter
l'impopularité du dispositif et que dans
ces conditions elles appliquerait un
dispositif aveugle qui consisterait à
diviser par deux pour tout le monde les
trajectoires si ça devait être le cas
l'idée qui est une sorte de déclinatoire
de compétence pour ces régions pour
faire en sorte que celle qui veulent pas
l'exercer on puisse imaginer un système
préfectoral ou départemental n'est pas
un truc qui me choque par avance et on
ça fait partie des sujets sur il faudra
que nous revenions il y aura de toute
façon la nécessité d'un texte législatif
compte tenu des bouger dont je suis en
train de parler tout ne sera pas de
l'ordre du réglementaire je vous
associerai à la réécriture évidemment
des des crêtes du 29 avril pour que les
mêmes causes ne produisent pas les mêmes
effets et d'ici la fin de cette année
c'est l'objectif que je me fixe on
pourrait avoir un temps définitif après
les quelques réunions que nous avons eu
pour regarder la liste à la fois des
points de convergence et de désaccord et
le meilleur véhicule législatif pour y
parvenir il me semblerait de bonne
politique à tout point de vue que six
mois avant les élections sénatoriales
des signaux clairs soit envoyé à tous
les élus de ce territoire sur ce qui se
passe pour éviter que des
interprétations ou des procès
d'intention ne viennent polluer le mois
de septembre prochain
très bien merci beaucoup pour ces
premières réponses je n'ai pas rebondir
j'aurais envie de temps en temps mais
j'avais laissé la parole à mes collègues
si je retrouve la liste mais je vais
donner la parole à Daniel grimilliet
d'abord notre rapporteur oui merci
Madame présidente monsieur le ministre
alors je me risque à ce que un certain
nombre de questions qui touchent et qui
soit hors champs mais votre titre fait
que malgré tout la cohésion territoriale
c'est pas tant hors champ que cela donc
je mérite ma première question monsieur
le ministre concerne la fiscalité
énergétique cette année si la fiscalité
énergétique est en baisse de 14% par
rapport à 2021 les dépenses fiscale
liées au programme sans strok 174 leçons
aussi de 4,5% par rapport à 2020
plusieurs évolutions fiscales
introduites dans le projet de loi de
finances par l'Assemblée nationale me
semble problématique se focaliser sur
une baisse de la déisme et Fe sans
prévoir celle de la ti-cgn est curieux
se focaliser sur une baisse
conditionné pardon les réductions de
taxes foncières aux critères de la re 20
20 et prématuré ne pas intégrer
pleinement le biogaz l'hydrogène bas
carbone bioéthanol et le biogazole à la
thyrote et regrettable enfin remettre en
cause les redevances hydro-électriques
alloués au collectivités est
inacceptable le gouvernement est-il
disposé à revenir sur ses dispositions
dans le débat au Sénat ma deuxième
question porte sur ma prime rénov si
cette prime est montée en puissance tant
dans son montant que ces bénéficiaires
et Leslie encore très largement les
propriétaires bailleurs et les
copropriétaires en 2022 ils n'ont
représenté que 3000 primes versées et
160 engagés sur un total de plus de 450
000 c'est totalement insuffisant comment
y remédier à cette difficulté je vous
rappelle monsieur le ministre que le
Sénat avait déjà fait des propositions
et souligner ce sujet de la copropriété
sur le sujet de la prime rénov ma
troisième question concerne le chèque
énergie son montant entre 50 et 250
euros et pour bien trop faible face à la
hausse des prix des énergies un chèque
spécifique et envisagé dans le cadre du
pdfm 2022 qu'elle pourrait être son
niveau ainsi que les ménages concernés
et le gouvernement envisage-t-il de le
prolonger l'échec carburant et fioul
l'an prochain cela constituerait un
signal positif pour les ménages les plus
précaires notamment ceux isoler en zone
rurale ma dernière question un trait au
crédit de la mission sur lesquels j'ai
au moins trois sujets de préoccupation
tout d'abord le menton provisionné pour
le projet d'enfouissement stokamine
est-il suffisant car nous savons qu'un
contentieux est en cours et pourrait
retarder ces opérations plus encore la
Rev des moyens humains et financiers de
l'ADEME engagés sur cet exercice sur
sont-ils reconduits et amplifiés sur le
prochain car on sait que le rythme
d'attribution du fond chaleur
renouvelable ne permet pas d'atteindre
des objectifs de la PPE et que le
personnel de l'ADEME peine à instruire
les projets présentés dans les cadres
des plans France relance et France 2030
dernier point pour la seconde année les
crédits attribués aux associations en
charge de la qualité de l'air diminue
pourquoi persévérer dans cette
contre-productivité pour la
décarbonisation de notre économie voilà
Monsieur le Ministre les points que je
me suis osé à vous poser avec le risque
que j'ai évoqué très bien monsieur le
minis je vous propose de prendre
l'intervention de Claude madurès si vous
êtes d'accord vous avez des questions
précédentes
je sais bien je vous prends par les
sentiments
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le ministre pour ces
explications préliminaires et en fait
j'avais des questions j'en ai moins
parce que deux de métro ont été posés
donc on va gagner du temps j'ai plus
qu'une question à vous poser qui
concerne les transports les transports
constituent une des principales sources
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
depuis 90 les émissions de ce secteur en
France ont augmenté de 9%. donc le
développement de véhicules électriques
apparaît comme l'une des meilleures
opportunités de réduire nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre la première mine de
lithium pourrait s'ouvrir à échassir
dans l'Allier en 2028 il s'agit
également d'une opportunité de
développement industriel puisque elle
nous permettra partie d'être en mesure
de produire des batteries pour ces
véhicules donc ma question est la
suivante quelles actions sont prévues
par le gouvernement dans ce domaine dans
le domaine de ce métal et dans celui des
autres terres rares pour que l'ensemble
de la chaîne de valeur puisse être
maintenu et développée en France
si je propose de prendre des groupes de
cinq interventions donc pierre creeper
s'en suit très micardon
oubliez Valérie pardon alors Valérie
Valérie pardon Valérie excuse-moi
monsieur le ministre chers collègues
je vais revenir pour ma part tout
d'abord sur la mission zan et le sujet
du Zéro artificialisation net puisque
comme vous le savez la mission commune
de contrôle du Sénat sur la mise en
application du Zen que j'ai l'honneur de
présider vous ayez en convié très
prochainement à une audition spécifique
sur ce sujet je ne vais pas
effectivement rentrer dans le détail
mais malgré tout
vous livrez quelques réflexions d'abord
je m'étonne que les discussions et les
réflexions sur Lausanne qui se sont
intensifiées depuis le début de l'année
2022 n'est pas encore abouti à ce que le
gouvernement propose des évolutions
législatives ou réglementaires plus
rapidement sur de nombreux points en
effet et vous l'avez rappelé il y a
consensus parmi les acteurs pour adapter
le cadre existant on sait par exemple
que la nomenclature des sols
artificialisés n'est pas satisfaisante
vous y avez fait allusion mais en nous
disant qu'effectivement vous aviez eu un
retour des agences d'urbanisme
pour l'instant les décrets sont toujours
contraires au texte sur le stradet qui
est sorti de de de la commission mixte
paritaire qu'il faut mieux prendre en
compte la renaturation que le calendrier
sera difficilement tenable ou encore que
le traitement des grands projets
nationaux européens doit être affiné le
Sénat vous alerter sur ces différents
points depuis le mois de mars et la
présidente vous l'a rappelé le mois de
mars dernier voire même depuis l'examen
même du texte de loi climat résilience
en 2021 vous aviez indiqué avoir demandé
à vos équipes de retravailler ces
différents points mais pour l'instant
nous n'avons pas le retour sur
l'aboutissement de ce travail alors les
collectivités et vous le savez et ça
c'est quand même un sérieux problème
sont dans l'embarras car les régions et
les intercommunalités sont elles bien
tenues de se débrouiller dès maintenant
pour intégrer le zan à leur politique et
leur document d'urbanisme malgré tous
ces flous préjudiciables et les délais
sont toujours les mêmes et donc ils sont
tenus d'avancer sans connaître les le
jeu définitive ce qui est quand même un
sujet monsieur le ministre pourriez-vous
nous dire clairement ici au Sénat sur
lesquels de ces points vous êtes prêts à
apporter les adaptations nécessaires
vous nous avez livré quelques points
mais qui ne sont pas très précis sur
jusqu'où vous êtes prêts à aller et bien
évidemment surtout dans quel délai c'est
évolutions interviendront quoi qu'il en
soit notre assemblée et puisque vous
avez évoqué la possibilité d'un véhicule
législatif elle est prête à formuler des
propositions y compris législatives cela
fait plusieurs mois que notre mission de
contrôle il travaille et nous déposerons
en décembre une proposition de loi
sénatoriale pour adapter le cadre du Zen
sur laquelle nous pourrions évidemment
échanger en profondeur avec vous pour
essayer de trouver effectivement des
voies de consensus d'ailleurs et je
conclurai par ce point notre Assemblée a
adopté à une large majorité il y a deux
semaines un amendement au projet de loi
ENR porté par l'ensemble des membres de
notre mission conjointe pluripartisanes
créant une enveloppe nationale destinée
à traçabiliser des soldes des grands
projets tout en ne le tout en ne les
faisant pas peser sur les enveloppes des
collectivités un compte et à part vous y
avez fait allusion je rappelle que cette
mesure est absolument essentielle à la
bonne application d'usage car sans elle
des cibles chiffrées inatteignables de
réduction de l'artificialisation de
l'ordre de 85 ou 90 % en disant
s'imposeront sinon aux collectivités
nous avions échangé au préalable avec le
gouvernement qui s'est été déclaré y
compris publiquement plutôt favorable à
faire évoluer le traitement des grands
projets s'avère que nous avons quand
même reçu sur cet amendement adopté à
l'unanimité un avis défavorable du
gouvernement ce qui interroge sur le
comté à poire puisque le gouvernement
nous a livré un avis différent de ce que
vous venez de nous rappeler monsieur le
ministre pouvez-vous nous confirmer
aujourd'hui que le gouvernement est
votre ministère spécifiquement
soutiendra cette mesure votée par le
Sénat et la fera aboutir au cours de la
navette et excusez-moi monsieur le
ministre je sais que ça a été évoqué par
votre collègue monsieur Klein mais
euh vous le savez euh la situation
d'Action Logement est particulièrement
sensible monsieur Klein nous avait
alerté sur le fait que ce mardi 15 vous
aviez un échange avec l'action logement
pourriez-vous nous tenir informé des
suites qui vont être données vous le
savez Action Logement est un acteur
fondamental des politiques du logement à
la française il faut préserver Action
Logement il ne faut pas en faire l'outil
des politiques publiques de l'État
derrière c'est un outil du paritarisme
un outil qui permet d'accompagner les
salariés les travailleurs clés dont nous
avons besoin dans les territoires et là
monsieur le ministre nous comptons sur
vous pour préserver le modèle du
logement à la française
merci madame la Présidente de la mission
conjointe donc je donne la parole à
Pierre Cuypers puis à Rémi Cardon et on
aura des premières réponses merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Ministre que
vous l'avez indiqué tout à l'heure vous
avez également dans votre portefeuille
ministériel de la responsabilité de la
chasse alors comme vous le savez sans
doute la plateforme de pétition du Sénat
a été utilisée par nombre de concitoyens
pour demander l'interdiction de
certaines pratiques qui jugent contraire
à leur sensibilité et à l'idée qu'ils se
font du bien-être des animaux sauvages
pour d'autres et ils sont les plus
nombreux ces modes de chasse sont
pleinement parts de leur mode de vie ou
un fort caractère patrimonial quel est
votre vision de ces débats comment
allez-vous avancer peut-être avec nous
pour apaiser les esprits afin que chacun
soit respecté et reconnu dans sa
sensibilité ou dans cette traditions
Rémy
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre notre bloc communal est en
souffrance méprisé pressé et sommet de
faire toujours plus avec toujours moins
de parfois être comblé même les vides
puisqu'il y a un désengagement
progressifs de l'État il est vrai que
quand on regarde les faits avec la
poursuite de votre processus d'érosion
de la fiscalité locale par la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation la
réduction de la CFE et la future
suppression de la CVAE nos collectivités
sont victimes d'une recentralisation de
leurs ressources ce processus s'appuie
sur une philosophie tout simplement
néolibérale qui ne croit pas à
l'efficacité pour l'action publique de
la décentralisation comme si les élus
n'étaient pas aptes à gérer les finances
publiques si l'enveloppe nationale
consacrée à la à la DGF et étant légère
augmentation les modalités de calcul de
sa répartition entraîne des inégalités
inacceptables pour tous les maires et
les élus municipaux qui se battent au
quotidien pour leur commune plus plus
d'argent c'est bien le répartir
équitablement c'est encore mieux
d'ailleurs dans le détail 17 800
communes ont vu leur DGF reculer
tous les ans durant le premier
quinquennat cette situation est
inacceptable et frappe en majorité les
plus petites communes entre 2021 2022 et
d'ailleurs
9380 des communes de moins de 500
habitants étaient
concernés par une baisse de la DGF
constaté par ailleurs des niveaux de
dotation par habitant allant du simple
quadruple pour des communes de même
strat dans les mêmes EPCI et tout
simplement incompréhensible pour tous
celles et ceux qui œuvrent au quotidien
et au service de la ruralité dans des
conditions de plus en plus difficiles
alors avec l'inflation le coût
d'électricité qui exerce une énième
pression intenable sur les budgets des
collectivités malgré les efforts
consentis par les plans de sobriété de
différentes collectivités tout en
assurant en plus en parallèle la
continuité des services publics avec
l'augmentation des charges la question
est simple
allez vous enfin changer de braquet et
organiser une péricquation horizontale
plus forte et synonyme d'équité entre
les territoires
c'est très varié merci pour ces
questions très simples et effectivement
qui sont prêts un problème c'est sur la
TI FCE sur lequel je vous dis là aussi
que c'est totalement chez ma collègue
Agnès panier renachi donc plutôt que de
vous lire un élément de langage que je
vais demander un collaborateur de me
préparer ce qui me semble pas très
respectueux de du processus d'audition
parlementaire je vais vous répondre sur
toutes les autres questions mais sur
celle là si vous avez besoin qu'on vous
apporte des compléments on le fera en
liaison avec le ministère concerné
ma prime rénove
les chiffres 2022 à la seconde gens
dispose et ils ont été actualisés pour
cette audition c'est 11000 propriétaires
bailleurs sur 630
000 primes vous avez évoqué le chiffre
de 3000 sur 430000 on a une légère
amélioration du taux mais on reste
évidemment sur des niveaux qui sont
extrêmement faibles mais j'en profite
pour actualiser ces éléments et pour
dire que le processus d'étude étant un
peu plus long ce chiffre devrait
continuer à remonter d'ici la fin de
l'année il est pas exclu qu'on soit très
ou 14000 au moment où l'année se
terminera j'attire votre attention sur
le fait que nous prolongeons ce
dispositif propriétaire bailleur avec
certains considéraient que dès lors
qu'il s'agissait d'un deuxième logement
de gens il était pas souhaitable de les
aider ma conviction et que l'enjeu de la
rénovation énergétique nécessite qu'on
donne un coup de main sur tous les
logements de la façon qui tiennent
compte du niveau de revenu des gens mais
que il est souhaitable d'accompagner ses
propriétaires parce qu'il y a une
diversité et une réalité beaucoup
d'entre eux ayant parfois juste un bien
leur sert aussi à financer une retraite
après des professions libérales ou des
choses de ce type
le vrai sujet
plus large sur lequel on pourra revenir
c'est que
on a des marges d'amélioration pour ma
prime rénov il y a un succès objectif
qui est celui du nombre de rénovation
qui ont été entreprises près d'un
million et demi de logements en deux ans
c'est le niveau de trajectoire théorique
dont on a besoin par rapport à ce qu'on
s'est engagé à faire pour 2050 il y a 30
millions de logements dans ce pays dans
ces 30 millions de logements il y en a
10 qui sont classés ABC on a donc 20
millions de logements qui sont classes D
E F ou G pour qu'aucun logement ne soit
plus classe C en 2050 au-delà de classe
C en 2050 il faut donc rénover sur les
30 ans qui viennent une moyenne de 700
000 logements par an
en revanche il est pas interdit de se
demander comment on peut aller plus vite
et il est surtout pas interdit d'essayer
de mieux cibler les aides vers les
logements qui sont les passoires les
plus énergétiques et là on a un petit
biais puisque nous ne lions pas le
niveau de soutien à l'efficacité
climatique des mesures que nous prenons
sans doute parce qu'on ne mesure mal il
y a une critique très injuste par
exemple sur le fait dire il n'y a eu que
2500 passoires énergétiques
d'accompagner sur les 700 000 l'année
dernière ça n'est pas exact il n'y a que
2500 logements
qui ont qui ont payé un audit attestant
du fait qu'ils étaient sortis d'une
classe pour rentrer dans une autre ayant
donné lieu à une surprise en revanche
comme il n'y a pas de DPE obligatoire en
début et en sortie il est plus que
vraisemblable puisque 17% des logements
de ce pays sont des passoires
énergétiques que nous n'ayons pas que
0,5 % qu'il soit mais on a un système de
porte à l'entrée et de complexité
administrative qui fait que finalement
on dégrade nous-mêmes la vision qu'on
donne de ces résultats j'aurais
peut-être des occasions prolonger un
titre ou un autre sur le chèque énergie
le dispositif pour l'année qui arrive
qui consiste à faire en sorte à la fois
d'assumer 15% de hausse là où
normalement les priorius doubler ou
tripler sur une partie des énergies mais
de réserver des chèques à la moitié des
français puisque c'est globalement ceux
qui vont être concernés par les
dispositifs de soutien nous semble être
quelque chose de plus juste d'un point
de vue social que d'aller faire zéro
pour son pour tout le monde avec un coût
à ce moment-là pour les finances
publiques qui consiste indirectement à
financer des énergies fossiles et qui
nous aident pas à progresser sur un
autre domaine dans lequel il faut qu'on
soit capable d'avancer pour le carburant
l'idée c'est d'assumer un dispositif
pour les grands rouleurs pour ceux qui
n'ont pas le choix
le ciblage aujourd'hui tel qu'il est
imaginé qui se discute notamment du côté
de Bercy fait état d'une dizaine de
millions de personnes qui pourraient
être concernées dans le cadre des
dispositifs mais avec des critères qui à
ma connaissance
sa fille sur stockamine sur lequel vous
m'avez interrogé
vous savez l'intensité de ce sujet
d'enfouissement de déchets dangereux et
que les enveloppes dépendent de
l'ambition que nous avons avec des
sujets aussi bien auprès de la
Communauté européenne d'Alsace son
président qui a été reçu au ministère il
y a quelques semaines pour évoquer avec
lui les différents sujets à ce stade les
montants qui sont envisagés une
trentaine de millions d'euros sur
l'année 2022 une somme à peu près
comparable en 2023 c'est à la fois les
coûts de travaux et de surveillance vous
évoquez des contentieux qui pourraient
aboutir à ce que les procédés ou les
ambitions bougent il va de soi que dès
lors qu'il y aurait des décisions de
justice le ministère adapterait ses
crédits à ce que serait la réalité en
l'état je parle de ce que je connais des
montants qui sont inscrits et qui
correspondent au sujet sur lesquels nous
sommes engagés
vous m'interrogez sur l'ADEME la dame va
connaître une progression de ses
effectifs de 25 emplois pour l'année qui
arrive et le fond chaleur va être
pérennisé à son niveau du plan de
relance c'est-à-dire qu'on passe des 370
millions d'euros ou 520 j'ajoute que les
prix de l'énergie actuelle rendent
les retours sur investissement plus
rapide indépendamment du fond chaleur
donc on a un double effet qui est le
niveau de soutien mais on a aussi une
rentabilité des dispositifs pour avoir
dans une autre vie présidé une
collectivité locale qui est si à gérer
ses réseaux de chaleur y compris par des
SPL de manière à pas le faire sur son
budget principal et peser sur ses ratios
on a actuellement des conditions de
marché qui permettent d'accélérer de
façon très forte sur les chaufferies
avec des effets de levier qui peuvent
être moindres néanmoins cet effort d'un
demi milliard il correspond à une
réalité un engagement et je partage
votre idée qu'on a besoin derrière de
déployer vous m'avez ensuite interrogé
sur la question des agences de l'air si
je me souviens bien l'ordre dans lequel
vous avez fait les différents sujets à
mes connaissances on est sur une quasi
stabilité des montants
ces agences vont voir leur crédit de
surcroît complété par une partie
des amandes auxquelles l'État a été
condamné dans le cadre du non-respect de
la pollution de l'air ce qui fait que
quand on additionnera les deux on
devrait être sur des montants qui seront
en progression et non pas en diminution
même si sur les dernières décisions qui
ont été prises ça l'a été à titre
conservatoire constatant une
amélioration de cette qualité je vous
renvoie la décision du milieu du mois
d'octobre et je me tiens à votre
disposition si certains d'entre vous
avez envie de parler de ces des feux
pour varier les mots qui commencent par
Z et dont nous pourrions parler
sur la chasse
un petit verre
la chasse c'est c'est un sujet de
passion et on sent que comme beaucoup de
débats dans notre pays aujourd'hui
devient de plus en plus compliqué
d'avoir une opinion nuancée
il faut être pour ou contre avec une
espèce d'injonction qui consiste
désormais à choisir son camp il y a les
gentils d'un côté il y a les méchants de
l'autre et vous êtes d'un côté ou de
l'autre
je suis désolé de revendiquer le droit
et à la nuance et au consensus ou en
tout cas la recherche de compromis parce
que je pense que c'est la condition du
vivre ensemble et que à vouloir privé
les autres de liberté qu'ils ont fini
aussi par ne plus faire
vivre une diversité qui pourtant fait
notre richesse
sur le sujet effectivement les
initiatives sénatoriales ont suscité
beaucoup d'émotions de tous les côtés
j'en ai aussi bien entendu parler par la
Fédération des Chasseurs quand ils m'ont
rendu visite au mois d'août en début de
que par les associations
environnementales me demandant comment
les choses avaient évolué il ne vous a
pas échappé que
le gouvernement est plus
particulièrement mon ministère c'était
saisi des premiers sujets qui font
directement écho est-ce que vous avez
évoqué sur la sécurité de la chasse ou
nous avons aujourd'hui des accidents qui
résonnent d'une manière particulière et
qui nécessite un certain nombre de
bouger de la même manière nous avons
repris plus exactement défendu la
proposition du sénateur Cardou en
poussant une PPL qui a été reprise par
un député MoDem au sein de l'Assemblée
nationale et qui vise à supprimer les en
grillagements réalisés depuis 30 ans en
Sologne et éviter ce qui ne relève pas
de la chasse mais d'une forme de
ball-trap sur animaux vivants qu'on
lâche pour les gens qui sont là ainsi
que l'évolution des
des grillages pour en particulier qu'on
ait un minimum de 36 cm par rapport au
niveau du sol et un maximum de 1m20 qui
permettent que la biodiversité puisse
circuler et compte se retrouve pas comme
si le cas aujourd'hui avec ces 4000 km
de rempart qui entraîne un certain de
conséquences il reste des sujets que je
sais sensibles comme la question du
demi-jour sans chasse comme la question
de l'amélioration de la formation je
sais le temps que je dois prendre avec
le sénateur chaise pour faire en sorte
aussi de prolonger ces différents sujets
on vient de les faire entrer entre
guillemets dans l'atmosphère au travers
du déplacement de Bérengère Couillard
n'ayez aucun doute sur le fait qu'on
aura non seulement des occasions à
reparler mais peut-être même d'y
consacrer une audition de manière plus
spécifique parce qu'on a plein de sujets
y compris par exemple comme la question
qui n'est pas accessoire du plomb
et de la pollution plomb qui pose la
question de l'évolution vers les billes
d'acier avec la puissance des fusils
avec bref j'entre pas sur tous ces
sujets mais il y en a beaucoup on peut
aller vers la chasse traditionnelle on
peut parler du vano on peut parler de la
tendrerie de la pente bref je n'ai aucun
doute sur le fait qu'on aura des
occasions d'y revenir
je veux dire au président malgré que je
c'est un acte manqué j'ai sauté la page
qu'il concernait pour arriver
directement au sénateur Cuypers
l'annonce de l'exploitation d'une dans
une mine existante dans l'Allier d'une
capacité qui nous permettrait de
réaliser l'extraction de l'équivalent de
700 000 batteries lithium est une
excellente nouvelle pour la transition
écologique dans ce pays
on ne peut pas décemment soutenir l'idée
qu'il faut se passer du fossile
qu'on a besoin de garder des véhicules
individuels pour assurer une liberté de
mouvement dans un pays comme le nôtre et
que les terres vous les métaux dont on
aurait besoin on va les chercher au bout
du monde dans une hypocrisie qui serait
la plus complète
la mine de l'Allier permettra
l'équivalent à ce stade de 700 000
batteries en pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée nous fabriquons 1,3 millions de
véhicules par an en France évidemment
pas tous électrique mais ça correspond
donc à peu près à la moitié d'un parc
dans lequel 50% serait produit de
manière électrique c'est évidemment un
premier pas encourageant nous avons
besoin si on veut être souverain de
continuer à trouver des lieux qui nous
permettront de ne pas dépendre de
d'autres pays pour les matériaux
essentiels dont nous avons besoin la
sortie du fossile c'est bon pour le
climat je pense que c'est aussi bon pour
les droits de l'homme parce que ça nous
évite de dépendre de pays qui n'ont pas
nécessairement la même conception que
nous dans un certain nombre de sujets
mais c'est bon aussi pour notre
souveraineté tout court
et donc
les chiffres que vous donnez sont tout à
fait exacts les transports c'est 30% des
émissions et pour aller un peu plus loin
c'est le secteur qui a le moins amorcé
ça baisse non pas par rapport à 90 mais
même sur une période plus récente tous
les grands domaines des missions sont en
baisse pour certains de manière
prononcée on est à 23% de baisse de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre par
rapport à 1990 on a doublé ce rythme
modernique quinquennat mais il faut
qu'on le double à nouveau pour tenir nos
engagements et ça suppose un effort
particulier dans les domaines de
l'agriculture et des transports qui sont
à eux seuls 50% aujourd'hui des
émissions et les deux domaines dans
lesquels nous avons les baisses les plus
importantes à Calais la présidente les
Tarma interrogé sur le zan j'entends son
exaspération sur le fait de ne pas avoir
eu de réponse depuis le mois de mars je
plaide au moins la clémence entre le
début du mois de mars et le 4 juillet
date de ma nomination je vous demande
d'entendre que dans les quelques sujets
que j'ai trouvé dès le 29 août j'avais
eu l'occasion de
d'organiser avec plusieurs d'entre vous
un temps d'échange ensuite on s'est
rendu compte que c'était peut-être pas
stupide qui aurait des navettes
parlementaires d'associer les
parlementaires de tout bord et donc j'ai
conduit quelques sujets puis les
collectivités locales parce que aller
prendre la vie de l'AMF de la MRF de
quelques autres y compris pour avoir un
point de compromis acceptable nous
semblait être quelque chose de
nécessaire le délai pour la réécriture
du décret j'avais dit que nous n'aurions
que mi-novembre les conclusions des
avances des agences d'urbanisme on l'a
depuis hier j'ai donc vraisemblablement
en ce moment même sur mon bureau des
pistes pour réécrire ces fameux décret
du 29 avril je procrastine pas j'attends
juste à la fois de pouvoir les lire et
ensuite de les partager avec vous pour
rester dans l'esprit de co-construction
que nous avons conduit je vous confirme
que c'est pas seulement la position du
ministre mais la position du
gouvernement le comté à part sur le plan
national là-dessus il n'y a pas de sujet
notre idée sauf que l'enjeu c'est de
présenter l'ensemble de tout ça de
manière cohérente et globale et nous
sommes interpellé en particulier par les
régions qui demandent des comptes à part
régionaux pour certaines d'entre elles
notamment pour accompagner des projets
économiques ou pour le fait de savoir où
ça commence et ce qu'un projet de giga
batterie d'usine de gig est un projet
national
je donne cet exemple et là-dessus
comprennent un minimum de temps dans le
cadre d'une discussion pour savoir
jusqu'où on va la dernière demande que
j'ai c'est quand même qu'on sorte les
pistes cyclables des trajectoires
d'artificialisation ce qu'il a nous fait
descendre un chant et un domaine de
manière différente et qui suppose
d'autres types de discussions et
jusqu'où on dit des tricote le texte de
quelle manière c'est juste pour vous
dire que dans le cadre de la discussion
maintenant qu'on l'a initié qu'on fait
en sorte d'avoir tout le monde autour de
la table il faudrait pas qu'on termine
comme on a commencé c'est-à-dire avec un
défaut de concertation et d'échange on
est là-dedans mon objectif c'est je l'ai
dit d'aboutir le plus vite possible et
qu'on est au plus tard fin d'année une
position complète de notre part et donc
votre perspective d'un texte en décembre
permettrait sans doute que
devant l'émission pour échanger et bien
écoutez vous me laissez le temps de lire
les propositions de la snow et les
divers points et je serai ravi de venir
vous m'avez ensuite interrogé sur Action
Logement
j'ai effectivement reçu hier matin pas
seulement le président arcadiepan et son
fils président mais toutes les
organisations syndicales les 7
organisations syndicales qui assurent la
gestion paritaire d'Action Logement
19000 salariés premier groupe de
logements social 33% des logements
sociaux financer à 80% du npnée
financera 1,5 millions d'actions cœur de
ville et je pourrais ajouter un certain
nombre de choses la garantie visa à la
hauteur de 600 000 développées dans le
pays et un acteur clé d'un lien emploi
logement
il y a une émotion factuelle qui n'est
pas une position du gouvernement qui est
une position d'une structure
indépendante qui s'appelle l'Insee sous
le contrôle de rostat
je insiste sur le sous le contrôle de
rostade puisque c'est dans le cadre de
la procédure européenne or que dit
l'Insee elle considère qu'il faudrait
reclasser Action Logement service qui
est la filiale qui prélève le 1%
logement enfin
le PEC à l'intérieur du périmètre des
administrations publiques locales ce qui
engendrerait comme conséquence qu'elle
aurait besoin d'une dérogation pour
continuer à emprunter
si on prive Action Logement de la
capacité à emprunter
on flingue le secteur du logement
je peux pas être plus clair vous
conviendrez avec moi que ce terme sont
pas diplomatique mais ils ont au moins
le mérite de la clarté je les ai assuré
hier dans le cadre de cet échange et de
ce dialogue de la conviction qui était
la mienne que nous avions effectivement
à faire en sorte de au contraire de leur
donner des perspectives et je souhaite
que nous aboutissions avant la fin de
l'année madame la Présidente l'État à la
signature d'une nouvelle convention
kanale laquelle nous sommes attelés à
l'issue de la réunion d'hier matin
donc autant vous dire que les choses
sont
engagées de cette manière ce sujet avec
l'Insee ça n'est pas un bras de fer en
l'espèce avec le gouvernement je le
redis
j'ai en tout cas très clairement
les conséquences
elles font le elles peuvent être prises
d'une certaine manière je préférerais
qu'à la fin on finisse par ne pas les
intégrer mais si elle devait l'être on
aurait tout à fait la possibilité à la
seconde où elle serait reconnue dans ce
périmètre de leur accorder la dérogation
d'emprunt qui permettrait de revenir au
système antérieur sauf qu'elle serait
intégrée dans la trajectoire
maastrichienne ce qui serait pas une
bonne nouvelle pour la comptabilité de
nos finances publiques et pour la
nécessité qu'action logement soit un
acteur important y compris de la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
dans le cadre des cinq années qui
arrivent on a quelques sujets
périmétriques dont je ne parle pas mais
pour lesquels je fais votre disposition
sur leur trajectoire financière sur la
contribution du snap et sur quelques
autres sujets que vous connaissez au
moins aussi bien que moi
il me semble que j'ai enfin été
interrogé par le sénateur Rémi Cardon
sur la question de la DGF
je me souviens avec émotion
de l'époque où j'ai fait mon entrée dans
cette maison comme vice benjamin du
Sénat comme quoi le temps passe mais un
âge bien plus avancé que le sénateur
carton il y a cette époque non seulement
la DGF n'a pas été maintenue mais elle a
baissé dans des positions que n'avions
jamais connu alors le gouvernement n'y
était pour rien puisque c'était un
gouvernement socialiste qui était en
responsabilité et je comprends que vous
ne reprochiez de ne pas avoir abandonné
de 700 millions d'euros la DGF pour
l'année en cours et que vous voudriez à
réquisitoire sur une partie des sommes
qui n'ont pas été compensées mais la
plus grande des budgétisations qui a eu
lieu c'est celle qui a consistait à
priver l'ensemble des collectivités
locales de 12 milliards d'euros je
considère qu'à un moment quand on
s'inscrit dans une famille politique on
a le droit d'avoir un minimum de mémoire
au moins dans la façon dont on pose la
question et dont on présente les choses
pour être clair un certain nombre
d'impôts ont été supprimés mais ils ont
été compensés on peut discuter de la
question de l'autonomie mais pas du
niveau de compensation
je mets au défi qui que ce soit sur la
taxe d'habitation de trouver des écarts
par rapport à la réalité contenu du
décompte et je vous annonce que la
suppression de la CVA elle a des biais
elle a en particulier le biais de nous
faire prendre un risque sur le lien
entre l'activité économique et
territoire ça on peut en parler mais sur
le niveau de compensation la vérité
c'est qu'à la fin les collectivités
locales seront gagnantes
et je vais très exactement vous dire
pourquoi parce que le négociation elle a
abouti à ce que la compensation elle se
fasse par un régime plus dynamique dont
on ne voulait pas Bercy à l'origine
la CVAE c'est 2,5% de moyenne de
progression depuis 10 ans la TVA c'est
3,5
je vous invite à regarder ces chiffres
et à la différence de la CVE la TVA
n'abc qu'une fois autour de au cours de
ces 25 dernières années c'était en 2009
alors que la CVE connaît des itérations
qui sont liées au mécanique donc on peut
discuter de la philosophie et de la
libre administration mais vraiment sur
la compensation et j'en veux pour preuve
un élément sur lequel je m'arrête
dans le concert des difficultés
actuelles qui sont liées à l'inflation
et sur lequel on pourrait revenir
il y a un niveau de collectivité que
nous entendons pas
ce sont les régions
parce que la progression des crédits
liée au fait qu'on a supprimé pour elle
la CVE pour la TVA ça aboutit à 9,1% de
progression des crédits ce qui est très
supérieur à ce qu'aurait été le régime
de ces VF et ça au moins cette
inconvénient d'indexer en quelque sorte
une partie des recettes sur une partie
des dépenses
je pense qu'on aura des débats
passionnants parce que je ne réagis pas
parce que la loup la liste est longue
monsieur le ministre mais on aura des
débats passionnants là-dessus je passe
la parole à Serge gabarit ensuite à
jean-clotisso
oui merci président monsieur le ministre
le gouvernement abondait la mission
écologie de 3 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires pour financer un
amortisseur électricité il indiqué dans
l'exposé des motifs qu'il couvrira
également les établissements publics
c'est ce qui est une bonne nouvelle
pourtant nous avons proposé la question
au mystère de l'économie personne ne
sait s'il réseau consulaire constitué
justement d'établissements publics et
bien inclus dans ce dispositif on nous
répond d'ailleurs souvent qu'il faut se
tourner vers votre ministère pour avoir
la réponse
pour ne prendre qu'un exemple les
chambres de métiers de l'artisanat
pilote des centres de formation des
apprentis qui s'acquittent une lourde
facture pour les équipements techniques
comme les fours par exemple puisqu'ils
font les formations de boulanger
pâtissier etc et rien qu'en 2023 la
facture des chambres de métiers va
s'alourdir de 15 millions d'euros alors
qu'il est prévu de les secrets de 15
millions d'euros par ailleurs
pouvez-vous donc aujourd'hui nous
confirmer si le réseau consulaire
bénéficiera bien de l'amortisseur
électricité en tant qu'Etablissement
public je vous remercie deuxième la
réponse est oui deuxième question c'est
une bonne réponse
deuxième réponse j'espère qu'elle sera
aussi positive mais c'est plus long et
plus compliqué le réseau ferroviaire à
son rôle à jouer dans la transition
écologique bien sûr simplement
l'interrogation c'est reçu un flambée du
coup de l'énergie qui met aujourd'hui en
péril le Fred ferroviaire il y a eu un
certain nombre d'interrogations autour
de cela avec le risque de transfert sur
le routier quelle mesure comprendre le
gouvernement pour préserver ce mode de
transport merci
la première porte sur le montant accordé
sur le fond vert en estimé à 2 milliards
d'euros en fin d'accompagner les
collectivités territoriales dans les
projets de transition économiques on a
l'impression un petit peu mais je
comprends pas mais vous allez nous
écrire le sujet j'en ai pas l'impression
que c'est du recyclage d'enveloppes
entre DETR des cils etc donc ce premier
outil semble malheureusement bien
insuffisant par rapport aux 12 milliards
d'investissements nécessaires 12
milliards d'investissement climats qui
devraient être réalisés par les
collectivités chaque année selon un
rapport récent d'institut d’économie
pour le climat et collectivités ont
pourtant et on le dit tous ici un rôle
clé à jouer dans la mise en oeuvre des
politiques de transition écologique qui
peuvent avoir un rôle moteur auprès des
autres acteurs du territoire que ce soit
les entreprises ou les citoyens quand on
voit les récentes recettes de la
contribution au service public de
l'électricité estimé à près de 31
milliards d'euros d'autant plus que ces
recettes se créent dans les territoires
ne pensez-vous pas monsieur le ministre
il conviendrait d'augmenter les fin au
fond vert ça c'est une première question
enfin deuxième question je souhaitais
revenir rapidement
c'est vraiment
l'actualité revenir sur le potentiel
prolongation d'un an de l'autorisation
de la mise sur le marché du glyphosate
par la Commission européenne suite au
désaccord entre les experts des 27 États
membres sur le sujet du glyphosate qui
concerne conjointement votre champ de
compétence c'est vrai et celui de
Monsieur féno la France a obtenu le
statut d'État rapportant en 2019 au sein
d'un groupe de travail dédié et
malheureusement et je rejoins les propos
de notre collègue euro député Henri
Andrieu l'échec des négociations prouve
le manque de travail et de volonté de la
part des quatre états rapporteurs alors
que la stratégie européenne pour la
biodiversité et la stratégie de la ferme
à la fourchette prévoit une réduction de
la moitié de l'utilisation des
pesticides ici à 2030 ce nouveau report
est un coup dur porté à ses objectifs
donc ce ministre quelle est la position
de la France votre position dans ces
négociations européennes pensez-vous que
les financements publics à la recherche
d'alternatives sont à la hauteur de
notre pays donc ça voilà et puis j'ai
une question qui est récurrente que j'ai
posée à tous vos prédécesseurs
on vous parlait du sujet de la mine dans
l'Allier moi je vais vous parler du
sujet de l'après mine et j'ai un sujet
très très précis c'est une mine
d'uranium dans mon département
savoir
l'après mine est très mal géré on a eu
plusieurs rencontres avec les
différentes prédécesseurs et on en a eu
un il n'y a pas très longtemps avant que
vous arriviez avec le cabinet de Madame
Pompili on n'a pas eu de réponse parce
que vous êtes arrivés trop vite où elle
est partie trop vite je sais pas mais en
tout cas mais je souhaiterais à nouveau
qu'on puisse se rencontrer parce que
c'est un sujet très précis et qui
devient très urgent merci Monsieur Merci
beaucoup Jean-Claude Silvia Noël et on
finira ce cette série pour Patrick
chaise merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre vous évoquiez tout
à l'heure le défi de la voiture
électrique et la nécessité devrait pour
sauvegarder notre capacité de production
dans notre pays où au moins sur le
continent européen je vous rejoins tout
à fait mais je profite de cette audition
pour vous alerter sur les difficultés
extrêmes vécues par l'industrie
automobile électro intensive qui
supporte actuellement des hausses
électricités de plus de 300%
j'en ai j'ai bon nombre de
sous-traitants automobiles dans mon
département qui m'a alerte sur les
vraies difficultés qu'il rencontre
aujourd'hui et donc demain je vous
alerte déjà sur le fait que bon nombre
mettront vraisemblablement la clé sous
la porte parce qu'ils ne seront pas en
mesure de supporter de telles hausse de
coude l'énergie donc si on veut demain
pouvoir avoir encore la capacité de
produire nos propres véhicules je crois
qu'il va falloir véritablement
accompagner cette industrie qui est
capitale deuxième question c'est sur le
filet de sécurité
destinée aux collectivités locales
votées lors du PLF du 16 août 2022
reconduit en 2023 selon les propos du
gouvernement en juillet 2022 il était
question que ce dispositif concerne
22000 communes or le ministre des
comptes publics auditionnés par le Sénat
le 26 septembre dernier indiqué que seul
25% des communes soient à peu près 9000
pourraient en bénéficier donc là encore
je vous demande de nous communiquer des
chiffres réalistes parce que on est un
peu perdu merci
Sylviane Patrick chaise
je vais être assez rapide puisque mon
collègue qui perce attiré avant moi je
vais
je vais quand même revenir sur la
question de la chasse et sur le rapport
que nous avons remis sur la sécurité qui
effectivement comme vous l'avez dit
monsieur le ministre a
créé un syndrome de réaction divers et
variées moi la question que j'ai à vous
poser est très simple c'est que je
voudrais savoir comment votre
gouvernement envisage de gérer ce
dossier et plus particulièrement si vous
prévoyez de porter une loi sur
cette question dans le dans le courant
de l'année
vous êtes à l'amortisseur pour tous les
autres
y compris si vous avez moins de 10
salariés mais que vous avez un besoin
important en énergie type boulangers et
si vous êtes électro intensif c'est le
guichet c'est à dire un traitement au
cas par cas pour les sites les plus
industriels pour éviter les conséquences
que vous avez décrites parce que là
l'idée c'est de pas des industrialiser
le pays à cause des prix et donc ce
dispositif spécifique qui sera
directement pilotée par Bercy qui
concernera plusieurs dizaines centaines
je ne sais pas de sites qui ont un tel
poids dans leur chiffre d'affaires plus
exactement dans leur dépenses de la
partie énergie il y aura un suivi pour
les accompagner pour convenir avec elle
d'un niveau de soutien qui leur permet
de rester compétitive ça c'est le
guichet pour les électro intensifs
en ce qui concerne
la question du fret et la question de la
SNCF
le Sénat a fait un excellent rapport sur
le développement du fret je le dis parce
que il nous inspire avec Clément baume
sur la manière dont on pourrait majorer
ça et qui d'ailleurs pointent bien le
fait que il y a la question du prix mais
malheureusement il y a pas que la
question du prix il y a la question de
la taille des plateformes il y a la
question du nombre de sociétés qui
interagissent dans le domaine et du fait
qu'on n'a pas de système d'accroche
intelligent et donc on a un temps homme
qui est extrêmement élevé et qui
complique une partie des usages on a
plus de sillons qu'on ne le croit mais
on n'a pas forcément assez de wagons ou
de temps pour les assembler ou de place
sur les plateformes pour pouvoir le
faire et pour pouvoir tenir nos
engagements
la question du fret et du soutien global
du financement des coûts de la mesure la
SNCF va être concernée par les
dispositifs de soutien l'énergie tout le
monde l'est les amortisseurs et les
dispositifs de guichet s'inscrivent dans
ce contexte et valent aussi bien pour
une collectivité que pour une université
publique que pour une entreprise
publique et donc à ce titre il y a des
modélisations qui sont en train d'être
faites par rapport au prix que la SNCF
avait pu
contracter
je veux dire au sénateur Tissot que le
fond vert c'est 300 millions d'euros de
recyclage
avec des guillemets un milliardet de
crédits nouveaux la décile la DETR ne
baisse pas ce qui change c'est que le
fond friche qui aurait dû disparaître
qui était doté de 300 millions d'euros
qui auraient dû disparaître dans le
cadre du plan de relance mais dont on a
vu l'efficacité on le reprend entre
guillemets parce que clairement les
friches font l'objet du financement par
le fond vert mais on est bien un
milliardet de crédit nouveau et dans la
progression des crédits global
vous avez c'est 2 milliards d'euros de
plus hors relance ou ce 1 milliard 7
relance comprise je vous assure vous
pouvez vérifier le dispositif et ça j'y
éveillé personnellement vous me fait
dire que potentiellement on n'est pas
tout à fait à la hauteur de ce que
serait les besoins pour accompagner les
collectivités territoriales qui peuvent
être un maillon indispensable sur la
cohésion des sur la transition
écologique je partage l'idée que c'est
un maillon indispensable en revanche il
nous faut un outil de dialogue commun
j'ai demandé à la MF à intercommunalité
de France à l'ADF et à l'ARS de nous
proposer des maquettes de budget vert
non pas édité par Bercy mais faites par
les associations de collectivités qui
nous permettraient ensuite d'avoir des
bases pour savoir ce qui va dans le bon
sens pour le climat et donc de pouvoir
ensuite là dessus objectif et des
soutiens qui nous permettent d'accélérer
d'un point de vue climatique voilà ce
que je peux vous dire et l'idée c'est
que ça puisse s'appliquer dans un an
qu'on dispose de ces maquettes parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez des
collectivités qui toutes seules dans
leur coin vous disent moi j'ai un budget
qui est bon pour le climat mais elles
font une compta maison et par exemple
elles peuvent prendre une route et vous
dire que comme il y a des vélos sur la
route la route c'est bon pour le climat
qu'on est un minimum de modèles me
semble pas être quelque chose d'aberrant
si on veut être capable de parler la
même langue je vais sur la question du
glyphosate alors qui n'est évidemment
pas
le sujet le plus simple à la fois parce
que vous l'avez dit il est européen
parce qu'il y a une forte résonance sur
le ministère de l'agriculture sur le
sujet et qu'on est dans une situation où
je prends acte
j'y suis bien obligé que le vote des
États membres n'a pas permis qu'une
majorité qualifiée se dégage pour que on
sorte aux échéances prévues c'est-à-dire
au 31 décembre 2022 dispositif la
position de la France c'est de continuer
à plaider que nous devons aller vers
l'interdiction la plus rapide possible
en soutenant les alternatives en termes
de recherche et ce qu'on est en bon
niveau les dispositifs de soutien à la
recherche pour les alternatives au
glyphosates pour le coup je les pilote
pas en direct donc je ne peux pas
répondre à la question est-ce qu'on met
assez d'argent pour trouver ces
alternatives
il n'y a plus de doute aujourd'hui sur
le caractère néfaste pour la santé du
glyphosate donc de ce point de vue il
est
indispensable qu'on est une accélération
d'évolution c'est pratique et l'Europe
doit avancer le sujet c'est aussi
au-delà de ça c'est la directive REACH
c'est quelques autres sujets sur
lesquels
nous pourrions avancer j'étais rendu sur
l'après mine je prends le point que il
vous faut un temps spécifique pour
évoquer la situation de votre ancienne
mine d'uranium de la Loire
la sénatrice Noël pour l'électro
intensif c'est fait pour le filet de
sécurité
je vous invite
et nous y réfléchissons très activement
à assouplir le filet de sécurité que
vous avez grandement déjà contribué à
mettre en place dans le courant de l'été
il se trouve que d'après les éléments
qui me reviennent on a un problème sur
la porte d'entrée on s'est mis d'accord
sur le fait qu'il fallait un niveau de
diminution de l'épargne brut pour
pouvoir bénéficier ensuite d'une partie
de la prise en charge et il semble que
ce soit ça qui soit le problème c'est
qu'on a je vais le dire avec des mots
que je vous demande de pas retenir
contre moi mais c'est parce que je n'ai
absolument pas la difficulté pour les
collectivités locales mais on a
surestimé la perte d'épargne brute que
subirait les collectivités et ça n'est
pas parce que vous perdez que 15% que
vous allez bien et que vous ne devez pas
disposer d'un coup de main donc le
dispositif tel qu'il a été prévu la
porte est trop étroite et ça aboutirait
à ce qu'on ne dépense pas les fonds que
vous avez obtenu dans le cadre de la
discussion budgétaire et les 430
millions et j'attire votre attention que
fort du précédent 2022 le filet de
sécurité adopté à l'Assemblée nationale
qui s'inspire pour partie de ce
dispositif avec une perte d'épargne
brute de moins 25%
gagnerait sans doute a été assouplie
dans des conditions comparables
je sais que le sénateur USON dit on
supprime la première partie on prend en
charge 50% du surcoût c'est à dire il y
a même plus de porte d'entrée à titre
perso mais ministériel aussi je vous
indique que l'absence totale de porte
d'entrée ne semble pas forcément juste
mais qu'en tout cas il faut une porte
d'entrer beaucoup plus basse peut-être
que 10% de capacité de perte
d'autofinancement permettrait déjà pour
le coup de retrouver les chiffres que
dont nous parlons mais à 25 on est sur
des volumes qui prive un trop grand
nombre de collectivités du dispositif
voilà ce que je pense très exactement
sur le sujet et encore une fois je le
dis à peu près avec le souci de
consommation des enveloppes sur
lesquelles il y a eu des engagements de
prière donc ensuite si on décide d'aller
plus loin on peut mais on ne dépensera
pas les 430 millions dans les conditions
actuelles du filet de sécurité on a un
petit sujet sur les chiffres c'est que
c'est sur la base des comptes
administratifs qu'on versera l'argent
donc quand quelqu'un vous dit on
espérait 22000 ou on pensait 22000
aujourd'hui c'est 9000 d’autres vont
vous dire 5000 tant que l'année n'est
pas terminée il y a potentiellement une
question qui peut se poser
en revanche comme on a des collectivités
qui pensent qu'elles ne seront pas 25%
elles ne demandent pas l'avance
remboursable et celle pour lesquelles on
est certaines qu'elles dépasseront ce
seuil elles ne sont pas nombreuses mais
il faudrait pas qu'on ait des
collectivités qui se débrouillent pour
creuser leur perte au titre de l'année
de manière à bénéficier du filet de
sécurité en repoussant du coup certains
dispositifs il faut pas qu'on pénalise
la bonne gestion je le dis mais
qu'on ne me fasse pas dire ce que j'ai
pas dit vous pouvez par exemple différer
la subvention que vous versez à une
structure de chez vous pour faire en
sorte de bénéficier d'un complément de
crédit c'est de la bonne gestion si
c'est pour toucher une subvention mais
ça n'est pas souhaitable qu'on pousse
les élus à ce type d'expédian il faut
qu'on les aide en tenant compte d'une
réalité objective
le sénateur chaise m'a interrogé sur le
fait de savoir s'il y aurait une loi je
sais pas lui répondre à cette date
y compris parce que il y a des choses
qui pourraient sans doute se faire par
décret
et que je ne sais pas jusqu'où on va sur
un certain nombre de sujets je dis pas
que c'est impossible je peux pas prendre
cet engagement ce soir parce que quand
je dis quelque chose j'aime bien ensuite
le faire et comme je suis pas certain
qu'on en aura besoin mais je pense que
ça fera partie des sujets dont on pourra
parler très bien merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre on va reprendre un jeu de
questions Serge méryou ensuite
Marie-Noël line madame la Présidente
Richard collègue moi je vais je voudrais
évoquer la forêt et derrière la forêt
les moyens et le budget de l'ONF et
d'éventuelles suppression de postes qui
ont été largement évoqués je rappelle
que le budget de l'ONF c'est 180
millions d'euros légèrement en hausse un
projet pour pour 2023 mais on a une
inquiétude donc sur les effectifs de
l'OMF avec une suppression de 95 postes
prévues pour 2023 et dans le cadre de la
mise en oeuvre du contrat d'objectifs il
pourrait y avoir et de performance il
pourrait y avoir des suppressions à
l'ange qu'à 500 postes
je rappelle qu'un rapport sénatorial qui
était qui est récent et sur les feux de
forêt et bien sûr les syndicats c'est
évidemment le rôle demande au
gouvernement de revenir sur la
suppression des 500 postes je pense
monsieur le ministre que vous vous êtes
exprimé récemment le 29 octobre et que
vous avez indiqué qu'il y aurait aucune
suppression de poste pour 2023 mais
pouvez-vous nous confirmer donc pour
2023 et la trajectoire aussi sur les
cinq années à venir je vais pas refaire
le l'article sur l'importance de la
forêt avec la mutation à laquelle elle
est confrontée merci Jean méthode et
ministre répond voilà rapidement à
chacun d'entre vous après vos questions
progression des crédits aux alentours de
10 millions d'euros suppression des 80
postes qui étaient prévus dans le schéma
d'emploi je peux pas répondre pour
l'année qui suit pour une seule raison
c'est que les effectifs de l'ONF sont au
ministère de l'Agriculture il y a une
cote tutelle donc moi je connais mes
perspectives de postes pour les 5 ans
qui viennent mais la feuille de route
ONF on s'est battu ensemble avec Marc
féno pour qui est zéro suppression pour
l'année 2023 je ne peux pas imaginer
qu'on reprenne une baisse au moment où
on annonce qu'il faut qu'on augmente les
plantations qu'on arrive à 10% du
renouvellement de la forêt dans les
années qui viennent contenu de la baisse
du pouvoir de stockage je rappelle que
l'on nef gère 25% de la forêt française
et que
ça ne représente que 4% des surfaces qui
ont brûlées preuve qu'il y a aussi un
dispositif de prévention et
d'accompagnement que là-bas ont fait les
corridors de sécurité qu'on réalise les
obligations débroussaillement et qu'un
des sujets c'est de regarder comment on
éteint le périmètre qui permet la bonne
gestion par le NF de ces sujets mais en
tout cas les choses sont claires 0
suppression 10 millions de compléments
pour 23 merci marine Noelle lineman
ensuite Patricia
vous êtes le ministre de la
Planification et je vais prendre
l'exemple de la de la rénovation
thermique des HLM s'il y a bien un
endroit où pourrait planifier c'est là
on a des opérateurs bienveillants
capables on a fait un chiffrage
qui amène jusqu'à 2050 à des sommes
gigantesques
faut pas faire le truc faudra trouver
les moyens de le faire
la l'Union sociale pour l'habitat
demandé dès cette année que soit
consacré au moins dans les deux
premières années qui viennent 500
millions d'euros à la rénovation
thermique
500 millions d'euros pourquoi parce que
le fond le plan de relance mettez 500
millions pour 2 ans et tout a été
consommé en une année sachant qu'il y a
encore en attente des demandes de
subventions
l'actuel budget prévoit 200 millions ça
veut dire qu'on commence à cumuler du
retard alors que même avec les 500
millions on n'est pas sûr d'atteindre
les 350 milliards etc donc ne
croyez-vous pas que soit dans le cadre
du plan de confiance ou de l'accord de
confiance que le gouvernement veut faire
avec l'USH soit par une procédure
spécifique il ne soit pas urgent de
planifier de façon pluriannuelle fiable
la montée en puissance de la transition
énergétique j'ai parlé de rénovation
mais il y a l'histoire de la seconde vie
des bâtiments très anciens qui est aussi
une piste mais qui ne peut pas couvrir
tout de suite l'ensemble du parc
deuxième sujet très rapide aménagement
du territoire
on entend pas de discours sur les
nouveaux outils la nouvelle stratégie
d'aménagement du territoire or ça
devrait être impérativement un
corollaire aux ânes parce que si vous
avez une stratégie de rétraction des
trop fortes du foncier sans l'avoir
planifié dans une stratégie
d'aménagement du territoire vous allez
avoir une désertification des services
publics etc qui va s'opérer et en
particulier on l'avait vu dans la
mission recherche innovation beaucoup de
nouveaux de nouvelles entreprises et
usines ne peuvent pas attendre 10 ans
avant de savoir s'ils peuvent
s'installer à tel ou tel endroit donc ne
faut-il pas un plan de foncier
disponible pour un certain nombre
d'usines et d'entreprises qui prennent
du terrain je parle pas de la petite
entreprise intellectuelle qui a pas
moins besoin de travail de terrain de
planifier les terrains facilement
mobilisables compatible parce que sinon
dès qu'il y a un projet tout on se dit
je suis pas sûr d'avoir mon permis etc
troisième volet elles font friche le
fond friche est dans le fond vert
est-ce qu'il y a des crédits
sanctuarisés et moi j'ai pas tout
compris de qui elle est décider de
l'usage du fond vert donc si vous pouvez
nous expliquer en même temps qui va
décider dans quel transparence et sur
quels critères de priorité ça nous
paraît utile
sur le ministre
parc social
le parc social est globalement en
meilleure état que le parc privé et
j'attire votre attention sur le fait que
dans les débats qu'on a sur la
rénovation énergétique on a discuté des
bailleurs notre principal problème c'est
les copro et le principal verrou il est
pas financier il est juridique pourquoi
est-ce qu'on arrive à faire des
rénovations collectives dans le parc
social parce qu'il faut pas une majorité
de soutien parmi les propriétaires à
coup en se heurte aujourd'hui c'est aux
droits de propriété et à la nécessité de
réunir une majorité pour être capable de
faire les travaux bilan il y a deux fins
moins de passoire énergétique 9,5 contre
18,8 dans le parc social plutôt que dans
le parc public mais ça représente quand
même 460 000 passoires pour lequel
indépendamment du calendrier que vous
évoquez qui est juste pour 2050 on a des
besoins à court terme
je vais pas ce soir entrer dans le
détail vous avez raison je ne remets pas
en cause les chiffres que vous donnez je
considère que le dispositif deuxième vie
peut être un moyen d'aller redonner une
défiscalisation à partir d'un certain
niveau de rénovation qui permettrait
d'enclencher d'accompagner tout le monde
mais je pense qu'il y a un autre angle
mort dont nous allons nous occuper dans
les toutes prochaines jours ou semaines
qui sont les bâtiments des collectivités
locales et de l'état je vous parle de
380 millions de mètres carrés à 1000
euros du mètre carré en moyenne ça fait
400 milliards
et donc quand on met ce genre de
chiffres on comprend qu'à un moment il
va falloir qu'on innove indépendamment
des crédits budgétaires et que nous vous
proposerons des choses qui sont
innovantes dès lors que ces publics
j'aurais l'occasion d'y revenir plus
vite que vous ne le pensez
le meilleur moyen d'atteindre nos
objectifs carbone c'est de fermer nos
usines comme ça on dira regarder on est
même moins sauf que derrière on
importera des trucs qui sont produits au
bout du monde et ce sera totalement
hypocrite donc c'est l'inverse qu'il
faut faire il faut rien industrialiser
ce qui suppose effectivement d'être
capable d'avoir cette vision et pardon
et vous m'aviez posé une question le
fond friche
attribution le préfet répartira ses
crédits sur le modèle de la DS il reste
un point c'est est-ce que
on fait une commission dans lequel le
préfet réunit une partie des mers un peu
sur le modèle ou des parlementaires sur
le modèle de la DETR pour faire en sorte
de d'attribuer les crédit ou pas ça
c'est en discussion avec la MF
ça serait la meilleure solution je suis
transparent avec vous bon mais l'idée
c'est que les crédits soient disponibles
vite
très bien merci Patricia Sillingy pose
sa question ensuite Martine Berthet
merci à tout le monde d'être court merci
monsieur le ministre vous avez annoncé
récemment à fléchage de 50 millions
d'euros pour un programme de recherche
sur l'adaptation des forêts au
changement climatiques ce programme vise
à apporter des solutions et des outils
d'aide à la décision aux propriétaires
pour avoir la forêt la plus résiliente
possible pour capter piéger du carbone
pour avoir des stratégies intelligentes
en termes de plantation d'exploitation
et de suivi est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner plus de précisions sur ce
programme aussi est-ce que qui nous
permet d'espérer qu'il soit mis un terme
à la malforestation c'est rangé serré de
pain aligner sans lumière que l'on
rencontre parfois dans le Limousin ou
d'autres dans le Morvan
merci Patricia parfait très rapide 50
millions d'euros pris dans le cadre du
Plan France 2030 sur la partie forêt la
raison très simple
aujourd'hui nos forêts alors qu'elle
progressent en volume elle diminue en
efficacité de stockage carbone le plus
gros écart que nous ayons sur la SNBC il
vient de l'insuffisance stockage que
nous avons pourquoi parce que la forêt
est victime du réchauffement climatique
et donc au lieu de nous aider elle est
affaiblie et donc il faut qu'on renforce
sa résilience 50 millions d'euros pour
un programme que nous confions à l'ONF
or trajectoire budgétaire puisque c'est
dans le cadre de France 2030 quelles
essences par rapport aux températures
qu'on connaît quel type d'essence on
peut planter par rapport au sol pour pas
être aussi dans de la monoculture
comment est-ce qu'on fait en sorte
d'avoir une stratégie qui soit une
stratégie de biodiversité et un volet
qui est l'utilisation du bois
parce que le sujet c'est que le bois
c'est non seulement une capacité de
stockage mais ce sont aussi des sources
de matériaux biosourcés qui nous
permettent d'éviter d'autres types
d'énergie il faut là dessus se méfier de
deux phénomènes le phénomène Idéfix je
ne coupe pas un arbre je laisse la
nature telle qu'elle est parce que une
forêt jaune c'est une forêt qui absorbe
du carbone une forêt vieille si une
forêt qui stocke mais on a besoin
d'avoir une forêt qui pousse de manière
à absorber une partie de ce qu'on aimait
et donc il faut être capable d'avoir ce
double dispositif et en même temps il
faut qu'on sache ce qu'on fait de cette
forêt parce que si c'est derrière pour
faire du bois énergie ça veut dire qu'on
rebrule ce qu'on a stocké donc qu'on
l'imagine pour des haies pour un certain
nombre de choses c'est une chose mais
que ce soit la destination à ce
moment-là ce serait une difficulté
ensuite je peux pas répondre sur le type
d'essence ça dépend évidemment de la
stratégie mais c'est l'objectif que vous
décrivez mais ça dépend aussi de la
nature des sols et dans certains
endroits où vous avez du sable la
possibilité d'aller varier les essences
et les limitée par la nature
très bien merci Martine Berthet ensuite
Bernard buis oui merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
questions portent sur deux sujets les
aides et des feux et le loup le loup
pour commencer que pensez-vous de sa
protection à tout prix alors qu'il
entraîne ou que sa gestion entraîne la
disparition d'autres espèces de Phone et
de flore je pense au mouflon qui a
disparu de plusieurs massifs alpins qui
l'entraîne également la disparition du
pâturage de nos alpages pourtant
bénéfique à la protection de
l'environnement pourquoi à présent que
le comptage des nombres plus de 1000
loups un nouveau seuil de 2500 loups est
sorti du chapeau pour la viabilité de
l'espèce versus les 500 demandaient
jusque là quel est votre position pour
son déclassement d'espèces ultra
protégés à protéger comme nous le
demandons et l'ont demandé tout
dernièrement une quinzaine de pays
européens concernant les aides et Fe
quelles aides alors les collectivités
territoriales concernées commencent à
s'affoler parce que quelles aides sont
prévues pour ces collectivités
territoriales je pense à la nécessité
dans mon département de changer tous les
bus de transport public pour les
agglomérations chambérienne et aixoise
quelles aides et exonération et comment
président d’interco ou maire des villes
qui sont concernées par ces ETFE pour
que dans les différents domaines dont
vous parlez et ça a été évoqué la
question des touristes la question
effectivement de la de la réalité
d'usage très court on puisse d'abord
avoir un partage d'expérience à ceux qui
sont passés il y a 10 et des feuilles il
y a 43 villes maximum qui sont concernés
dans les 43 il y en a une dizaine qui
devrait sortir de l'obligation contenu
de leur qualité de l'air et très
concrètement c'est avec eux qu'on
discute deux angles la question de
l'harmonisation la question de
l'accessibilité sociale il y a des
dispositifs qui sont prévus d'être de
prêt à taux zéro de microcrédit de
surprises à des feux j'entre pas
là-dedans parce que dans les questions
vous posez il y a aussi des réponses
tout n'est pas binaire aujourd'hui dans
les 10 vous avez une ville comme
Strasbourg qui applique un dispositif au
24 fois par an
même si vous avez une voiture qui n'est
pas critère en critère de vous pouvez
accéder partout dans la ville si on
généralisait des dispositifs
d'exonération temporaire pour des
touristes ou pour des choses de ce type
ça pourrait régler une partie du sujet
aujourd'hui mais on peut très bien
imaginer demain que ça se fasse avec
d'autres types de dispositifs y compris
l'aide de la technologie la lecture des
plaques d'immatriculation l'exonération
de certains véhicules à Reims on a sorti
les véhicules de secours au TP de la
liste des véhicules qui sont concernés à
Grenoble pour le mont les véhicules
légers ne le sont pas sont les poids
lourds je vais pas entrer dans le détail
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
depuis quelques semaines deux fois par
an le principe a été rendu concevoir
avec l'ensemble des mers pour répondre à
ces sujets une campagne de comme pour
rappeler qu'il s'agit dans ce jeu de
santé publique et pas d'une fabrique à
gilet jaune la volonté de faire en sorte
effectivement d'avoir des aides qui
soient au niveau et je reviens à ma
discussion sur l'électrique tout à
l'heure aujourd'hui mon problème c'est
que pour sortir d'une partie des
véhicules polluants je n'ai pas
forcément les alternatives d'occasion
qui me permettent d'avoir des réponses
qui sont crédibles la question des buses
des réseaux de transport du GNV ou d'un
certain élément ça va le résoudre à
l'échelle du ministère il faut pas qu'on
ait des aberrations qui consiste à
flinguer les transports en commun alors
même comprétant prendre des alternatives
à la voiture donc je peux vous assurer
que sur ces sujets j'aurais des
occasions de revenir vers vous
le loup les comptages dont je dispose
pour moi font état de 921 loups le
chiffre de 2500 je ne l'ai jamais
entendu
vous avez raison de dire que au moment
de la réintroduction le chiffre de 500
avait été évoqué comme étant très
concrètement l'ambition et l'objectif
d'un plan national ce plan national d'où
il arrive à échéance au premier
trimestre de l'année qui arrive la
France va devoir effectivement à la fois
définir ce qu'est sa nouvelle vision on
a plein de sujets à régler depuis la
question des Patou les chiens en passant
de l'action d'indemnisation le travail
de l'ofb la position sur la Convention
de Berne aller chez l'européenne on a
énormément de thèmes plus la
simplification d'un certain nombre de
tir de prélèvement vous savez qu'on est
sur 19% de tirs de prélèvement qui sont
autorisés et qu'on ne les atteint pas
parce que certains considèrent que ça va
trop loin or les 19%, il faisait partie
du deal et de l'équilibre qui avait été
passé y compris avec les éleveurs sauf
que vous avez des questions
d'autorisation administratives
l'interdiction des tirs multiples la
question des louvetiers la question de
leur équipement bref plus des angles
morts par rapport aux éleveurs
proprement dit qui fait que quand une
brebis a disparu en indemnise pas or
dans un certain nombre de cas il peut
arriver que le loup emmène la brebis
enfin bref
ce sujet un il fait l'objet d'une
mission commune entre le ministère de
l'agriculture et le ministère de la
transition écologique deux d'un
benchmark européen moi j'ai demandé
comment font les autres on est tous
confrontés au même difficulté vous avez
évoqué le sujet est-ce qu'il y a des
pays qui sont plus intelligents que nous
sur une partie du dispositif et ce qu'il
y en a dans on peut s'inspirer et ce
travail il va obtenir objectiver la
position que nous aurons au premier
trimestre de l'année prochaine pour
dévoiler un nouveau plan national d'eau
mais je n'ai jamais dit qu'on avait
besoin de 2500 loups j'ai jamais dit non
plus qu'il fallait qu'on revienne à 500
je sais qu'il y a des chiffres qui
circulent à la minute où je vous parle
et c'est une parole autorisée du
ministère de la transition écologique
on constate qu'on est dans une situation
qui arrive à point nommé l'émotion elle
est à son maximum dans les départements
où le loup arrive là où dans certains
départements et je pense à la Lozère
et au fur et à mesure que le loup est en
train de remonter vers le nord vers des
territoires qui n'ont pas l'habitude on
se rend compte de l'impact psychologique
et économique sur les populations et
donc la nécessité de nous poser la
question du bon ajustement de cette
politique
merci Martine
c'est de l'ours
merci président de monsieur le ministre
je souhaite vous interroger sur l'avenir
des zones Natura 2000 cet été la région
Auvergne Rhône-Alpes a décidé de
supprimer les subventions destinées aux
autres Natura 2000 cette décision serait
motivée par la baisse de 20% des crédits
des feders et le souhait de réallouer
c'est fort à l'agriculture or en
Auvergne Rhône-Alpes 13,3% du territoire
est classé en zone Natura 2000 ce qui
représente 938 443 hectares ce sont 266
qui sont protégés donc 47 sites dédiés à
la préservation des oiseaux de leur lieu
de reproduction des haltes migratoires
et zones d'hivernage et 213 sites
consacrés à la conservation des habitats
naturels une telle décision mais
évidemment en péril cette biodiversité
ainsi que les emplois dédiés à
l'animation et l'entretien de ces sites
monsieur le ministre que faire pour
préserver l'avenir financier de ces
zones Natura 2000 essentielles au regard
des enjeux essentiels de préservation de
l'environnement sur notre territoire
bon vous l'avez dit il y a donc ce
transfert des zones Natura 2000 pas de
toute l'état conservant les zones Natura
2000 en particulier maritimes mais des
zones terrestres avec effectivement la
région Auvergne grenade qui a une
position originale par rapport aux
autres régions de France qui consiste
effectivement à considérer que le
contenu est pas alors même qu'on est en
train de parler de crédit européen et
que dans le dispositif nous n'avons pas
la main complète sur ces crédits et donc
dans ce
dans ce sujet il me semble que c'est
quand même l'intérêt de préservation de
ces zones qui comptent nous transférons
de manière intégrale les ETP qui sont
associés à ces zones Natura 2000 mais je
veux croire à la fin que quand on aime
sa région et quand on y attentif on fait
en sorte de préserver les territoires
remarquables qui la composent et qu'on
réussira à sortir de tout ça par le haut
je vous précise que dans le projet de
loi qui vous sera soumis il y a à
nouveau une progression de la dotation
biodiversité qui vous est proposé en
augmentation de 25% et qui est la somme
qui est adossée pour les habitants des
communes Natura sont des compléments de
crédit qu'on vous propose d'augmenter
pour les habitants de ces communes qui
permettent d'aller soutenir des
politiques d'accompagnement de ces PNR
bien Guess
[Musique]
c'est que les 15% vont peser pour
beaucoup de ménages et l'ADEME qui est
sous votre responsabilité des gens avant
l'augmentation des tarifs que il fallait
tripler le chèque énergie pour sortir
les gens de la précarité énergétique 12
millions de personnes qui vont avec la
rénovation thermique parce que ceux qui
sont obligés de surchauffer c'est
évidemment ceux qui habitent dans des
logements plutôt insalubre donc est-ce
que vous êtes là aussi plutôt en accord
avec l'ADEME sur pérenniser le système
mais donner une enveloppe évidemment
supplémentaire pour que c'est gens qui
sont en situation de précarité
énergétique puissant sortir dans la
prochaine année et la deuxième question
très courte je pense qu'en même temps il
faut interdire les coupures
d'électricité sinon on va avoir un
certain nombre de gens qui au mois de
mars vont se retrouver en très grande
difficulté voilà c'est fini
bon c'est pas un pronostic dans la boule
de cristal c'est la comparaison avec les
États qui nous entourent la France est
le pays où les tarifs de l'électricité
ont le moins augmenté on peut le
contester le présenter d'une c'est
juste factuel c'est je constate quand je
regarde l'année 2022 que quand on se
compare à tous les pays qui nous
entourent nous sommes le pays où les
prix de l'électricité ont le moins
augmenté et quand je regarde l'année
2023 il est perspectives sur lesquelles
nous nous retrouvons et qu'on
additionnera les années 2022 et 2023
même s'il reste des zones donc que vous
décrivez mais elles ne sont pas on peut
discuter du fait de savoir si ça va
monter à X3 ou à fois 4 mais on peut pas
discuter sur le fait qu'on aura au moins
des augmentations qui seront supérieures
et très largement supérieur aux 15% d'en
discutant
j'ai un respect infini pour la
représentation sénatoriale je vous dis
et continue de la nostalgie que que
j'éprouve à la pensée que j'ai été à
votre place mais si vous voulez qu'on
puisse s'entendre où c'est une
discussion elle a lieu dans le couloir
ou c'est une réponse à vos questions et
vous me permettez d'aller au bout des
réponses que je vous formule au moment
où j'ai je vous ai laissé poser votre
question jusqu'au bout
le sujet que vous décrivez c'est le
juste il est il est juste si on a la
moitié de la population qui se retrouve
avec plus 15% et qu'on a des chèques
énergies qui compensent de façon
correcte pour le reste de la population
le delta vous conviendrait avec moi ou
pas mais qu'en tout cas il y a à la fois
une prise en compte des plus fragiles et
un accompagnement d'une réalité des prix
qu'on a juste par rapport à des prix du
fossile dont il faut qu'on sorte d'une
manière ou d'une autre notamment compte
tenu du mécanisme du marché européen qui
fait que c'est sur la base du gaz bref
je m'en fais pas l'article manifestement
vous le connaissez par cœur je n'ai pas
encore lu l'étude de la dame elle est
sur mon bureau sur le sur le détail et
donc je suis là aussi très précis avec
vous je suis quelqu'un qui quand il sait
ou qui croit savoir il répond quand il a
pas regardé le dossier il se garde de
prendre des engagements que qui sait pas
si il peut tenir voilà ce que je peux
vous indiquer de manière très factuelle
Ghislaine pampel qui demande depuis tout
à l'heure le loup merci
je vais revenir monsieur le ministre sur
le fond vert je vais être très rapide
comment c'est moyen vont-ils être
ventils dirigé vers les chantiers de la
transition écologique et ce qui aura un
impact direct pour les entreprises du
BTP et quel articulation avec la DETR et
la dotation de soutien à
l'investissement local vous venez de
nous assurer que la gestion de ce fond
sera confiée au préfet ce qui constitue
une garantie de l'agilité de ce fond
mais quand elle a répartition vous venez
aussi de nous dire que ces 2 milliards
seront distribués à l'échelle de la
population vous comprendrez monsieur le
ministre que pour un département comme
le mien de 75000 habitants c'est la
double peine donc j'ose espérer que les
critères vont évoluer dans le bon sens
pour la ruralité
et quant aux anges quelle mesure
budgétaire prévue sont prévus pour
accompagner en termes d'ingénierie les
communes des toutes petites communes
rurales dans cette transition vers la
sobriété française merci monsieur le
ministre
bon
alors
deux questions pas très simples
d'abord ma présentation était très
raccourci quand j'ai dit que c'était au
bénéfice de la population la vérité
c'est qu'on va faire très enveloppes
régionales et on va ensuite aller chez
de ses préfets de région leur demander
de nous proposer une répartition
départementale qui tiennent compte d'un
certain nombre de facteurs pour être
précis donc on sera pas sur une règle de
trois aussi basique le principe encore
une fois c'est d'essayer de faire simple
moi je considère que l'année 2023 c'est
l'année 0 et donc ce qu'il faut c'est
qu'on teste et surtout qu'on dépense cet
argent l'idée c'est si c'est bon pour le
climat c'est aidé vous voulez planter
des arbres vous voulez déminéraliser
votre cours d'école parce que ça évite
d'avoir des îlots de chaleur on vous
donne un coup de main vous voulez faire
un corridor de biodiversité c'est bon
pour l'environnement on vous donne un
coup de main vous avez une mesure sur
l'érosion du trait de côte on vous donne
un coup de main on est vraiment dans
cette optique en termes de porte
d'entrée avec ensuite
sur la des cils et sur la DETR des
crédits qui peuvent potentiellement
s'ajouter si on retrouve un certain
nombre de choses ou pas la question que
nous aurons à nous poser pas pour 2023 à
moyen terme c'est celle du fait de mieux
articuler les subventions publiques avec
nos objectifs climatiques parce que si
on est tous convaincu qu'il faut qu'on
accélère et que la question c'est
l'habitabilité de la planète ça n'est
pas stupide qu'on se dise qu'on arrête
de subventionner des dépenses brunes
pour reprendre les couleurs qui peuvent
exister d'où les budgets locaux parce
que j'ai d'abord besoin d'avoir un outil
de discussion qui permette de faire les
choses si je ne l'ai pas je ne sais pas
dans la discussion si je vais dans le
bon sens ou pas voilà pour aller le plus
vite possible sur le zan
les travaux du sénateur blanc
m'inspire sur les outils de financement
et je mets les pieds en place sur un au
dessus j'ai il faut pas seulement qu'on
réfléchisse à comment on aide à
dépolluer il faut qu'on renchérisse le
coût de l'artificialisation
et moi je considère que dans ce domaine
plus on va durcir la règle plus on va
créer de la valeur pour ce qui va
devenir constructible de manière
totalement arbitraire une forme de rente
en disant il y a plus que X hectares qui
vont y passer donc qu'on considère qu'il
y a un surprofit qui est lié au fait que
vous retrouvez au moment où vous vendez
votre terrain qui vaut 1 Euro 2 euros 3
euros ou 30 centimes en fonction des
territoires et dans la valeur est
multipliée par 100 par 1000 au moment il
devient constructible que là on est des
droits de mutation spécifique sur le
passage à l'artificialisation qui
permettent d'aller accompagner une
partie de mesures vertueuses ça ne me
choquerait pas de manière générale je
considère que la transition écologique
et ça planification c'est 22 chantiers
thématiques qui ont été évoqués par la
première ministre on insiste moins sur
les sept chantiers transversaux
transition solidaire est juste fiscalité
dans les deux premiers la fiscalité
c'est que à somme constante parce que je
crois que si on transforme l'écologie
comme prétexte pour aller fiscaliser les
gens on va les dresser contre un
objectif qui est souhaitable en revanche
qu'on aille baissé des impôts sur ce qui
est vertueux et qu'on les augmente sur
ce qui les pas qu'on se pose la question
par exemple de la fiscalité pour la
seconde main ou pour le recyclage qu'on
regarde pour les transports en commun
qu'on aille accompagner les processus
artificialisation avec des mécanismes
qui envoient des signaux pris ou des
signaux fiscalité en fonction de ce qui
est juste on en a besoin
Anne-Catherine Loisier et on terminera
avec Yves Boulou merci Madame la
présente alors justement pour rebondir
vos propos moi je pense qu'en matière de
de forêt ce qui manque vraiment beaucoup
aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre c'est
des systèmes déco conditionnalités aux
aides publiques qui n'existent pas et je
pense que c'est un ce sont des éléments
qu'il faut absolument mettre en place
pour qu'on puisse vraiment s'orienter
vers une stratégie
vers une stratégie vertueuse deux points
rapidement on a par les ânes ZF on n'a
pas parlé snap stratégie nationale des
aires protégées 30% du territoire qui
commence quand même à préoccuper nos
élus surtout que ça se fait souvent avec
très peu d'informations donc voilà
comment comptez-vous associé les élus
dans le cadre de cette stratégie et à un
point d'attention aujourd'hui on
rencontre beaucoup de difficultés liées
à des prescriptions du code de
l'environnement en matière de protection
d'espaces et d'habitat vous savez si ces
arrêtés nidification certainement
entendu parler voilà
propose qui pose problème
qui pose problème pour les la gestion la
gestion les travaux en forêt et qui
posent aussi problème monsieur le
ministre tout simplement pour les Old on
parle beaucoup aujourd'hui des
obligations légales des broussaillages
qu'on ne pourra donc pas faire ou très
difficilement entre le 1er mars et fin
juillet c'est quand même un vrai sujet
voilà au moment où ça a poussé donc
comment comment comptez-vous dépasser
ces obstacles et mettre en place des
systèmes peut-être d'adaptation sur les
territoires avec les avec l'OV avec
l'adréal merci
je pensais que vous alliez m'interroger
sur le troisième R qui était sur le
troisième Z qui était les ZRR parce que
le mot après les aides et des feux et
les ânes dans ce qui m'occupe il y a les
et derrière et le fait qu'on va arriver
en fin de dispositif je recevrai le
Parlement rural le 25 novembre vendredi
de la semaine prochaine qui sera une
occasion avec la MRF d'échanger sur un
certain nombre de questions et qui
permettra d'accompagner cette grande
semaine de l'Association des Maires et
avec au cœur de tout ça en particulier
les rapports commis par cette maison sur
l'évolution des ZRR et sur les suites
qui pourraient être donné je pense au
rapport
delc d'Espagnac mais il y en a eu
d'autres par le passé c'est le dernier
en date mais il y en a quelques autres
sur lesquels on aura l'occasion
d'avancer sur les snap et sur les 30%.
c'est très exactement la position que la
France s'apprête à défendre à l'échelle
mondiale lors de la COP 15 à Montréal
préservation 30% des terres et de 30%
des mers avec 10% de zones sur
lesquelles il y aura un niveau de
protection renforcé on le fait dans le
cadre d'une coalition que nous
conduisons avec le Costa Rica et qui
désormais a dépassé les sentiments on
est 112 amis que nous parlons et avec la
perspective d'essayer de convaincre le
plus grand nombre de rejoindre en ce
moment même si la journée biodiversité à
la cop27 au cours de laquelle Bérengère
Couillard est en train de continuer à
essayer d'élargir cette coalition pour
que je puisse aller dans un mois porter
essayer de défendre la vision la plus
large sur nos territoires on a déjà pris
un peu d'avance en fait il y a une
hétérogénétique situation avec dans
certains endroits pas de difficultés
voire des communes qui ont trop de zones
protégées compte tenu du PNR dans lequel
est se trouve ou de la zone Natura 2000
et d'autres plus de difficultés il y a
évidemment un travail de de maillage et
d'explications qui est à conduire sur
les nidification sur les sujets de ces
injonctions contradictoires en
particulier vous avez totalement raison
qui peuvent se heurter à des obligations
locales de débroussaillement parce qu'on
va avoir un habitat à l'intérieur on a
demandé à l'ofb qui pour le coup relève
de ma tutelle de nous proposer des
évolutions conciliation et c'est ce qui
amène parfois que le ministre que je
suis est amené à trancher par rapport à
des noms de dérogations parce que j'ai
deux objectifs qui
diffère qui sont tous les deux sensés
être écologiques mais qui à un moment ne
trouve pas de points de convergence et
il faut arbitrer entre les deux donc
c'est un travail de dentelle si j'avais
une boussole plus simple que celle qui
consiste à devoir regarder les
situations au cas par cas ce serait
évidemment très important vous avez 100
% raison sur les co-constitutionnalités
et si je peux me permettre je pense
qu'il y a un certain nombre de domaines
où il faut qu'on pousse la logique j'ai
été trop vite tout à l'heure sur les
véhicules électriques aujourd'hui toutes
les primes que vous avez pour acheter un
véhicule électrique votre seule
obligation en contrepartie c'est de le
garder deux ans
ça n'est pas raisonnable d'imaginer
qu'au bout de deux ans on peut revendre
un véhicule qui a fait l'objet de 10 000
ou 15000 euros de prime et vous devriez
durcir si j'étais parlementaire
la durée de possession y compris parce
que sinon on va organiser une filière de
revente où les occasions dont on parle
les bénéficieront pas à notre pays mais
bénéficieront potentiellement à des
voisins qui n'ont pas le même niveau de
prix mais sur lequel on aura des aides
c'est un exemple que je donne il
pourrait rien avoir d'autre un des
enjeux pour la forêt ça va être la
mobilisation de la finance carbone et en
particulier en provenance de l'industrie
aérienne pour qu'on a immobilisé ces
fameux crédits de compensation pour
aller financer des programmes de
forestation et donc on aura un levier
budgétaire durable au-delà des 150
millions que nous mettons pour l'année
qui arrive toujours dans le cadre de
France 2030 sur le plan de reforestation
qui pourra justifier quand on l'écrira
de se poser la question de ce qu'on
attend en face en termes
d'accompagnement
très bien il reste une question
dites-vous et après on vous libère
en dépit de l'opposition des députés le
gouvernement a profité du
49,3 pour rétablir les contrats Cahors
dans le projet de loi de finances pour
qu'elle évite que les autres positions
sur cette question c'est très court
c'est super et le problème c'est que la
réponse mériterait d'être fournie parce
que les contrats de Cahors il n'existent
plus le contrat de Cahors c'était quand
même l'obligation pour le président
d'une intercommunalité ou d'une mairie
ou d'un département d'aller signer chez
le préfet un engagement comme quoi il
allait enfin être vertu en termes de
gestion des finances publiques
si on ne le faisait pas on se retrouvait
dans la situation comme le président
cadet dans les Côtes-d'Armor ou d'autres
à risquer une prise de déggef quand on
est dans un département côtier avec une
terre bénie des dieux comme les côtes de
granit rose je comprends qu'on est des
niveaux de DMTO qui permettent de se
passer d'une partie des crédits de DGF
mais ça n'est pas le cas pour les
départements de l'intérieur je vous
réponds de manière claire ce que nous
avons dit aux associations des Lucé
malgré la velléité là aussi où les
interrogations qui avaient Bercy sur le
dispositif c'est un il est hors de
question qu'on propose un dispositif
vexatoire dont les résultats ont été
spectaculaires sur le plan de la
trajectoire des finances publiques mais
peu convaincant sur le niveau des
amendes des contrats de Cahors ça a été
40 millions d'euros en tout et pour
toute prélèvement pour un coût en termes
de déchirure de confiance bien plus
élevé
on a donc flingué le dispositif de porte
d'entrée et on a précisé que ce ne
serait que sur la base des comptes
administratifs 2023 c'est à dire au
milieu de l'année 2024 que s'il y avait
des dépassements par strat on
examinerait des dispositifs cette
équilibre globale subtile dans lequel le
ministère de la cohésion des territoires
c'était battu pour pousser dans le sens
de la confiance a été légèrement
ébranlée par le fait que l'échec de la
LPFP qui comportait le dispositif à
entraîner la disparition du mécanisme et
donc ça réintroduction dans le cadre de
la loi de finances sous le couvert de
l'article 23 mais
dans une écriture qui nous semble qui me
semble modifiable pour revenir à ce qui
était l'état d'esprit il y a finalement
une attente légitime des collectivités
locales qui consiste à revenir à cette
logique de confiance et il y a une
attente du gouvernement
qui est que un moment par rapport à
Bruxelles on soit capable d'expliquer
quand même qu'on a une trajectoire de
finance publique sur plusieurs années
si d'une manière ou d'une autre à
l'occasion d'une commission mixte
paritaire il y avait une forme d'accord
entre le Sénat et l'Assemblée sur ce
sujet ça rendrait caduque la nécessité
de disposer dans l'article 23 dont la
rédaction est abrasive pour les
associations d'élus
je peux difficilement être plus clair à
ce stade monsieur le sénateur
[Musique]
enfin toutes notion de contrats dans
lequel l'État fait pas la même chose que
les collectivités territoriales
ça nous laisse toujours un petit peu
pantois monsieur le ministre mais ça
nettoie une question c'est une remarque
voilà de fin d'audition je voudrais vous
remercier pour la rapidité et la
vélocité de vos réponses mais je pense
qu'on aura beaucoup de sujets à voir
ensemble encore dans les mois qui
viennent je n'en doute pas c'est un
plaisir